- Did you get an
overwhelming amount of people
in your Twitch chat
asking if we were going to Garnt's wedding
or when Garnt's wedding was?
- Yeah.
- As if they were also planning to go?
- They were like, "You're
gonna film it, right?"
I'm like, "No.
No."
- Times people are like,
"So this is a 'Trash
Taste' special, right?"
(all laughing)
- Joey fucking rocks up
with one of the fucking film cameras,
just like, "Yeah, what's going on?"
- GoPro on every corner of the room.
- Connor's got a GoPro on his
fucking forehead like POV.
(gentle rhythmic music)
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste."
I'm Connor and I'm with
the boys, Joey and Garnt.
- Hey, guys.
- It me.
- How many weeks has it been?
- Many.
- It has been many weeks-
- Like a month, I think.
- You do not know this,
but I've flown back to England
and flown back to Japan in the time.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Since the last, not
even the last recording.
- And then you gotta
go a week later again.
- So why'd you leave us, Garnt?
- Why did I leave?
Basically, I had to do
a marriage interview.
Now, normally people do it
a year or something before their wedding,
but unfortunately, due to-
- (indistinct)
- Yeah, due to travel restrictions,
I didn't have the opportunity
to go back to England
to basically do this marriage
interview, which is legally-
- Wait, so fill me in,
what do you have to do
at a marriage interview?
- Okay, I'll-
- Can they be like, "Yeah,
you haven't got the job"?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I'll get-
- So why do you wanna get married?
(all laughing)
- I'll get into why I had to do it
but legally, if I wanted
to be married in the UK,
you need to give something
called a notice of marriage
which is basically you're
telling the government
that you're planning to get married
and so it brings you to
the legal proceedings
to allow you to get married.
- Now-
- Right.
- So normally you can do
that a year or months before.
Unfortunately, due to travel restrictions
and us not being able
to travel back to the UK
or just it being incredibly difficult,
we put that off and we put that off
and we put that off and we put that off.
And then you have to legally give it
at least 28 days before you get married.
And by the time we gave it, it was 35 days
before we got married, so.
- So you're still in the guidelines.
- It's still in the guidelines
but it was awkward because
I had to leave the boys
for two weeks or something.
- It's like that kid who
finishes the assignment
the day before it starts.
It's like, I got plenty of time,
I got a couple of hours left.
- Yeah, so I was looking at the schedule
and I'm just like, "Fuck,
we got 'Trash Taste'"
and all this other work stuff
that we need to be doing
and I gotta give my notice of marriage
otherwise I can't legally get married
and I've put this off
for as long as possible
but it just makes it a bit awkward
because otherwise, I would
have traveled back to the UK
a little bit later.
- Yeah.
- Because now I'm back just
for literally about eight days
just to do my filming commitments
and film all the "Trash Taste"
episodes we need to film.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, I don't even know
if I'm going to tweet out
that I'm back in Japan
because-
- It's honestly not worth it, right?
- 'Cause by the time I tweet it out,
I'm gonna be tweeting out,
"Okay, I'm back in the UK now."
- Yeah.
- And so another thing
is that this is probably
the most timely "Trash Taste" episode
you'll ever be able to see,
because we are filming
this, what, three days-
- Three days.
- Three days before it actually
airs or something like that.
- Yeah.
- It is, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's the one time
where we can talk about current topics
and it's the one time
where it's just like there
isn't really any current topics
to talk about.
- Yeah.
Before we started, we were
like, all right, guys,
it's finally time.
We can talk about some timely things.
And we just sat here for five minutes
trying to think of a timely subject.
- Yeah.
- And we couldn't think of anything.
- We should just pick
something really irrelevant.
- Yeah.
- It's like, oh, that Will Smith slap.
(all laughing)
That's crazy.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, but yeah.
Basically this notice of marriage,
it was mostly just
about lawful procedures.
- [Connor] Right.
- Just making sure that we
can be lawfully married.
So normally they just
ask you normal questions.
Oh, I was being asked,
spell your fiance's name.
What is her name?
Hopefully I know her name.
They ask her-
- Wait, really?
That's the gotcha?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- No, it's like, spell her name,
then asked, what is her birthday?
I don't actually know
what would have happened
if I failed, by the way.
- Yeah.
- What if I didn't know her birthday?
- You don't really love her, do you!
- My last name's a pretty
tricky one to spell.
It makes no sense
so if someone got it wrong,
it wouldn't be like, "Ooh,
ooh, ooh, oh, got 'em!"
- Yeah, because-
- Like people who have
dyslexia and have a-
- Oh my gosh.
- And have a Polish fiancee-
- So it's like a-
- With 17 Zs in it.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, "Uh?"
- Because I think they wanna check
that it's not a sham marriage
- Right, of course, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like you're not getting married-
- Like you're not just doing
it for the VISA or anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But, yeah, hopefully you can
spell your partner's name,
know their birthday.
If you don't, now that you
know what's gonna be asked.
You need to know where
you're getting married.
- This'll be on the test.
- It is a test
because they separate you, right?
They're like, "Okay,
we're just gonna be asking some
simple questions, whatever."
- Yeah.
- And even though I know
it was simple questions,
just being separated, it was kinda like,
it kinda felt like being
in an interrogation
like, "Why are you here!
Why are you getting married!"
Like, "Is she your real wife?
Is she gonna be your real wife?"
It was nothing bad like that,
it was just details about,
basic details you hopefully should know
about your future wife
and everything like that.
And then we get to the
end of the interview
and then they fucking throw
you a curve ball, right?
So here's me asking-
- Why are you gay?
- Here's me being asked
to spell Sydney's name.
What is Sydney's name,
what is Sydney's birthday,
where are we getting married,
when are we getting married,
what are my parents' names,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then out of nowhere,
they just ask you,
"Are you in any way related
to Sydney Ann Poniewaz?"
And I'm just like, "What
do you mean, related?
As in, brother, sister,
cousin, anything like that?"
And I-
- I mean, hopefully I'm about to be.
(Garnt chuckling)
- I just fucking, the
fucking "Oreimo" music
starts playing in my mind.
I'm like, yo, is this
person a (indistinct) fan?
It was so out of left field
that I literally just...
And then I let out a laugh
and I looked him in the eye
and they just looked me dead
ass back, just like, "No."
This is a serious question.
I'm like, "No, I am not related.
I am not brother or sister.
I'm not her cousin or anything like that."
- What if they were just like,
"Does this song ring any bells?"
And just plays "ClariS."
(all laughing)
It's like, "Does this give
you any weird feelings?"
- Yeah, they actually said afterwards,
"You'd be surprised how
many people say yes."
- Really?
- I'm like, what?
I didn't realize I was getting married
in the state of Alabama here.
- Yikes.
- Apparently it's surprising
how many first cousins
try to get married in the UK.
- I guess there's a lot of groups
that have a tendency to
marry within families.
- Yeah.
Do you fail the test
if you say yes to that?
Or do they just, they're like, "Okay."
- I don't know.
- Uh...
- It's the incest test, okay.
What happens if you fail the incest test?
I don't know.
- Yeah, I wonder.
- [Joey] I got positive
on the incest test.
(all laughing)
- You can't legally marry if
it's certain closeness, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can't-
- Can you marry first cousins?
- I believe in the UK.
You definitely can't marry
if you're brother or sister,
I'm not sure about first cousins.
I don't know, I didn't really-
- How many degrees of separation-
- Luckily, I'll never
need to worry about that.
- How many degrees of
separation does it have to be?
- I don't know.
- Not that, I'm asking for a friend.
- This is like Google, when
you Google this too much,
Google's like, "For real?"
Oh, he nasty, man.
- [Camera Person] Perfectly legal
for first cousins to marry in the UK.
- Is it? Is it actually?
Okay, okay.
- Okay, so if you say
yes to that question,
then they'll be like, "We'll allow it,
but we're just gonna silently judge."
- Because they didn't just ask,
legally by blood, they were like,
"We include step siblings as well."
And I was just like,
it's "Domestic Girlfriend" all over again.
- Garnt's like, "Please don't get horny,
please don't get horny."
(all laughing)
- I'm like, "I've been
training my entire life
for this moment."
- How did they know what
my favorite tags were?
(all laughing)
- Just stands up, knocks the
coffee over with his boner.
(all laughing)
- I'm just nervous, I
swear, I'm just nervous.
- What do they want you to
do a 23andMe to prove it?
What do they...
If you just say, "No," are
they like, "All right then"?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause you look identical? No.
- Yeah, 'cause I was wondering
because we were legally,
we had to legally prepare
most of the documents
that we-
- Thought you were gonna say,
we were legally brothers then,
it was like, ah, we're legally cousins.
- No, so we had to prepare documents
which is all the standard documents
you would think you would need
to prepare for a marriage interview.
Your passport, your,
since we were flying in,
your tickets for flying in,
your proof of address, all
the standard legal documents
so everything else could be
easily proved via our documents.
I don't know how you prove
whether you're incest or not.
What if you say, "Yes"?
What documents would you need to provide?
- They just fucking high five you,
they're like, "Nice, dude."
(all laughing)
Nice.
Me too, dude.
I was just asking, I just wanna...
- That wasn't a legal-
- Anyway, you failed the test.
(all laughing)
- That was just for me.
- Is there a fucking
incest Tinder or something
where you...
I believe that's called
Facebook, isn't it?
- It's like the code, yeah.
- It's just Facebook, right?
(all laughing)
- [Connor] God.
- Have you joined any of
these Facebook groups?
- Oh my God.
Was it hard to get the
marriage certificate?
Like, nah, kinda just documents?
I mean, I guess you've lived in Japan
so maybe getting documents
for stuff is easy mode.
- Yeah, it's actually,
I mean, it's harder to get the documents
now that we live outside of Japan
because originally we
wanted a church wedding
and the more we looked into it,
the fucking harder it was.
Mostly because one, I'm not Christian.
It's only Sydney.
And also a lot of churches in the UK
are very strict about who they
allow to get married there
or the priests.
So a lot of the times
you need to be a regular at the church.
And if you're not, already have attended
when you're a kid or a regular
or your family goes there,
then you need to attend
for a month or something,
just so the priest knows you.
And that just wasn't an option for us
because it's hard enough
taking a two week holiday
away from the boys, you know what I mean?
I couldn't just go back to be like,
"Guys, I gotta attend church for a month."
- I gotta go to church.
- I gotta see the Lord.
- I gotta see the Lord, so, yeah.
Unfortunately we couldn't
get a church wedding,
but you know, that's all fine.
We can still.
Everything is all ready now legally.
We've booked the place.
- Nice.
- We've booked the registrar.
- Nice, excited to go.
- I am so excited to go.
I'm so excited for you boys to go as well.
- All you can eat, right?
- Huh?
- All you can eat, right, I heard.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, boy!
- I won't spoil everything
that we have planned-
- Don't do it, I'll be excited.
- Before the wedding-
- My only question, is there food?
That's all I need to know.
- There is food.
Yeah, yeah, aside from
planning my own wedding,
I actually also was able to
attend a friend's wedding
while I was back as well.
It was a very, very packed,
very, very packed trip for me.
I literally attended this wedding
the day after I flew back to Japan
to meet the other boys, I guess.
- The other boys.
- My other spouses, as Sydney says.
- Of course, of course.
- My boyfriends.
- Yeah, and it was so surreal
'cause it was the first
mate's wedding I've been to
and it was so surreal
because a lot of weddings now
have been delayed to this year.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause obviously with
COVID and everything.
That includes me.
So this year is just
fucking packed for weddings.
I think you're-
- I'm going to three.
- You're going to three
weddings this year, aren't you?
- I'm going to yours, I'm
going to my friend's in Ireland
and then I'm going to
my cousin's in Japan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And all of them were supposed
to happen two years ago.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And it's just all this year.
- Yeah.
So a lot of weddings have
been postponed to this year.
So I basically just got,
I basically got to see what
a wedding is going to be like
and seeing my mate get
married and everything
and seeing everything from
the audience perspective
before I'm up there,
standing up there myself.
- You did the beta test.
- I did the beta test, right?
(all laughing)
- Like, this looks pretty good.
I think we can go full launch soon.
- Yeah, and I'll be honest, mate,
I was fucking nervous as fuck.
Holy shit.
- Really?
- It was-
- But for someone else's wedding?
- Yeah, someone else's wedding, right
'cause I've known this guy
for almost as long as
I've known Sydney, right?
So I remember just being in the audience
and seeing him stand up there
and waiting for the bride to come out,
just seeing him try to keep it together
just made me think, "Fuck, man."
I'm feeling your nerves right now
'cause I know everything
he's going through.
And I'm just like, "This
is gonna be me in a month."
I thought to myself,
"Fuck, if I'm this nervous
in the crowd, how am I going
to be when I'm up there?"
When I'm up there standing-
- Garnt just passes out.
- There's gotta be an element
of stage fright, right?
'Cause you just have to do something
in front of all your friends.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Kiss, kiss.
- It was actually so funny though
because it was like we
were waiting in the venue
where all the family was and
the groom was up there on stage
with the wedding party and everything.
And you know, they had
this beautiful harp playing
and everyone was silent.
And then there was just
this small pause, right.
As the harpist was
changing to the next song.
The bride was already, I
believe five to 10 minutes
after the ceremony had already
been scheduled to happen.
So we weren't nervous,
but it was just tense.
You could cut the tension with a knife.
Everyone wasn't talking.
And then there was this brief silence.
And then out of nowhere,
because Sydney was one of
the bridesmaids, right?
Out of nowhere, we just
hear in the corner,
just someone going, "Yes, God, yes!"
- Oh my God.
And everyone just started laughing.
And the tension was gone,
tension was just instantly gone.
- Give whoever said that a metal plate.
- But no, it was, yeah...
It's weird attending a mate's wedding.
I'm curious to see-
- I'll let you know.
(all laughing)
- I'm curious to see how
you guys react as well.
'Cause for me, I was
just, after it was over,
it's just such a nice feeling.
It was the most, like every
cliche you could imagine,
but it's cliche in a nice way.
'Cause it's how everyone
describes being at a wedding
but you're just drunk on positive vibes.
You're just so happy for
the couple and the future
and the bride and the groom
and just seeing them tie the knot
and just seeing them go through all that
after you know both of them
and after you've seen them
build up their relationship.
It's just such a weird moment
just to see everything culminate
into this one awesome moment
and it's just awesome to be-
- It's just so wholesome.
- It's so wholesome.
- Yeah.
- Oh God, I was just.
I'm still glowing from
positive vibes from that event.
I'm just like, "Damn, man."
I can't wait, I can't wait.
I can't wait.
- I'm hype,
I'm very hype for it.
- I'm hype.
- Interesting 'cause it's
like my friends in Japan
and my friends in the UK
are gonna see each other.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So it's the same thing for you.
It's gonna be strange.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause I was
talking to Connor earlier
where mostly it's like,
for a lot of people,
it's just gonna be our Japan lot
and our UK friends
meeting for the first time
and Connor's the only one
who is kinda, got-
- Bridging between...
- Bridging between both.
- I know everyone, I'm pretty sure.
- He knows everyone, basically.
- It's gonna be interesting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause normally, when your friend groups
live in other countries,
they don't normally
interact with each other.
So it's gonna be really interesting.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Actually, one of the funnest
parts of the wedding planning
'cause we've been doing a
lot of wedding planning,
some of it's stressful, some of it not,
but by far the most funnest points
is I get to choose who
sits to next to each other-
- Oh man.
Puzzle level difficulty.
- Just segregating all
the Japanese white people
to one side-
- 10 out of 10 difficulty level puzzle.
- Yeah, so a lot of,
some wedding parties,
they do a soft segregation
between the-
- Soft segregate...
- And it is what it feels like.
- Bit of discrimination is
always necessary, you know.
- But it's not discrimination,
it's soft segregation.
- That's what we're calling it,
that's what we're calling it, right?
Because sometimes you go to a wedding,
you can clearly see,
that's the family table,
that's the one friend group table,
that's the other friend group table.
- 'Cause you always have people
you have to invite, right,
who you're like, I have to invite them
but I know they're gonna cause problems
if I put them near other people.
- So we decided to do
something a little different.
Without spoiling who sits next to who.
We had a fun time being like,
"Who would get along with who
while not knowing each other too well?"
So we had a think
about what kinda
personalities would get on
so we didn't sit people next to each other
who they might be so familiar with.
Not too far away from just
being complete strangers.
But it was a fun time
just pairing people up
and pairing friendship groups up
and just seeing the absolute
state of some of the tables
that we have planned
because we've basically just put all
of the fucking big
characters on one table.
- Oh no.
- Oh my God.
- And, yeah, it's gonna be a lot of fun
just to see if you guys get
along well with each other.
Because it's like, as you said,
it's like two friendship
groups kinda merging
because I don't actually
have so much family
coming to my wedding.
It's actually a small
wedding in comparison
to other weddings I've been to.
I don't know, what do you
guys count as a small wedding?
- I don't know,
most of the weddings I've been to
have been very much dominated by family.
- Yeah.
- Ours is 80% mates.
- Ah, that's good, then.
- Yeah, that's good.
- Oh, that's good?
Small weddings or medium sized wedding
is different depending on
whatever culture you're from.
100 people is, I'd say
a medium sized wedding,
that's medium.
100 people is tiny compared to
an Indian wedding, you know?
- Yeah.
- I was talking to a guy who
went to an Indian wedding
and they had 1,000 people
going or something.
- That's a concert.
(all laughing)
- Indian weddings are
basically what happened
if you actually go on your Facebook group
and you invite everyone
in your friend group.
- And everyone said yes.
- Yeah, and everyone said yes!
- And then they all get
to bring a plus one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
- Yeah.
- Part of the reason, because
we do have a massive family
but we didn't want a
massive, massive wedding
'cause that's just such a headache
so we were just like, "You know what?
We're gonna have the
main wedding in the UK
and then we'll bring the
wedding to the family.
We'll go on tour, you know what I mean?
We'll go on tour."
- The wedding tour.
- So yeah, we're having a
different reception thing
for our family in the US
and Thailand way after-
- That'll be nice, though.
- Yeah, way after the wedding.
- Go and hit up the globe, dude.
- Sorry?
- Going hitting up all
the spots in the globe.
- Mr. Worldwide.
- Mr. Worldwide here-
- Is going on tour.
Wedding on tour.
- Has to let the world know-
- Oh, you only had one wedding?
Cringe, dude. Cringe.
- Yeah, 'cause I don't know,
I want to be able to talk
to everyone at my wedding
and share the positive vibes, but-
- [Connor] Right, right, of course.
- When you get over to 100 or 150 people
which, it definitely would
have been our wedding
if we invited all of the family
from both our sides from abroad.
You get to a point where it's our wedding,
it's meant to be our happiest moment
but you don't get time to
share it with the people
that you want to share it to.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- You see everyone talking
but you, most of your interactions
are just, "Oh, you having a good time?"
You have a five-minute
conversation and that's it.
It's basically just like going
to a convention, you know?
And going to a panel or something
'cause that's the amount
of interaction I have
with people who line up
for a meetup or something.
- Yeah.
- But I want
more of an interaction and more time
to get to vibe
with people at my own
fucking wedding, I guess, so.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah, I don't know people handle
massive fucking weddings of
300, 500, whatever, you know?
- Yeah, 'cause I've been to,
I went to my friend's
wedding, Japanese guy
who I went to university with
and it's a tradition,
I don't know if it's a full on tradition
but usually the tradition is
if you have a full-time job,
you already have a job-
- You invite your colleagues.
- You invite your colleagues
and you invite your bosses.
- Oh yeah, the boss has to come as well.
- The boss has to go as well-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I went to it
and there was soft segregation happening
and I was on the table
of mates who I went to school with table
but we realized
that was one table out of
40 tables that were there.
- [Connor] Jesus Christ.
- Because there was probably
400 people at this wedding.
All work colleagues, all
bosses and all family
and there was just me
and three school mates
who were there just being
like, "Yeah, so how you been?
It's been a while.
I don't know any of these other
people, but good wedding."
- Did you have to line
up to give your blessing?
'Cause I've been to some weddings
where we have to do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you have to-
- Line up to give your
blessing? What's that?
- Yeah because there is so many people
at the wedding, right,
and the bride and groom
only have so much time-
- Everyone takes a turn lining up in line?
- Yeah, I went to a Thai wedding
where we literally had to line up
to be like, "Congratulations, guys."
And they had this stage
where they sat on a
fucking sofa or whatever.
- I've only been to white
people weddings, so I don't...
- I literally had to line up
to shake my mate's hand.
- Yeah.
- Oh.
What?
- Yeah, because after the
reception and everything
and during the food and stuff like that
and they're walking around and stuff,
saying hello to everyone-
- That's cool.
- Yeah.
- Like-
- [Connor] It's a very
good system, though.
- Yeah, it's a good system
but it was also weird just lining up
next to a bunch of salarymen
to be like,
"Oh yeah, I'm just here to
shake my mate's hand, you know."
- Efficient, I like it.
I like the efficiency of it all.
Oh, you didn't see me at the wedding?
Shut up, we got five minutes
and a handshake, fuck off.
(all laughing)
- It's like an idol handshake.
- Yeah, it is, right.
(Connor grunting)
- How many of my albums did you buy?
- I bought 10 of your CDs, yeah.
- You're just in the wedding like, ch, ch.
- [Camera Person] Asian weddings as well,
when you're lining up,
sometimes you can slip
some money to pass it.
- Wow.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Camera Person] I got you.
- What, like a back alley deal?
- I don't know if this
feels correct in saying
but it just feels like the
Supreme store of weddings,
Asian weddings are.
It's like how much can you flex?
Everyone brings in Supreme.
Everyone's like-
- Oh yeah, of course.
- It's like, oh look at this spread, dude,
way more food than you'd ever need.
Bring everyone you know.
Why?
Just so I can have the
capacity bigger on Facebook.
- Pretty much.
- 'Cause a lot of Asian
weddings I've been to,
it's like a statement.
You know what I mean?
It's like a flight.
- It's about sending a message.
- It is literally about sending a message.
- Is it trying to tell people
how successful you are?
Or it's like, what's the?
- I think it's more so about,
look at how happy we are
and this is the physical representation
of how happy and well off
we are for being happy.
- Yeah, because the
amount of wedding politics
that go into an Asian, it is a thing.
It is a thing, right?
'Cause it's not even about inviting
your immediate friends and family.
You got your parents'
immediate friends and family
and people you grew up with
and everything like that.
If you are not invited
to an Asian wedding,
you have fucked up in some way.
You know what I mean?
- This legit sounds like the Red Wedding
from "Game of Thrones."
- [Garnt] It is!
- You failed to invite me to the wedding
thus you have betrayed my clan.
- It is!
- You will die now.
You have insulted the House of Maneetapho,
you will not be forgiven for this.
(all laughing)
- Which is why I didn't want that side
just involved in my wedding.
- It's like a peace envoy.
Fear not, there is another!
(all laughing)
The scroll comes down.
- We've gotta appease the family.
(all laughing)
- Fear not, we are bringing
the wedding to you!
(all laughing)
- Burst open the doors.
- This is some "Game
of Thrones" shit, dude.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, I mean, every
Asian wedding I've been to
is the most extra thing
I've ever seen in the world.
And it's unfortunate that it's
also extrapolated by the fact
that every Asian family I
know is fucking massive.
It's absolutely massive.
You have to invite-
- Especially Southeast Asia.
- Especially, oh my God.
If I had my wedding in my,
I'd then have to invite all my cousins
and all my-
- Cousin's colleagues.
- Just the entirety of
Bangkok, essentially.
- My cousin's colleagues.
- The entire population of
Bangkok at Garnt's wedding.
(all laughing)
- So yeah, that's,
I definitely would not
have been able to plan that
along with just being outside the country.
So I was like, "Fuck that shit.
I'm just gonna have a
small, manageable wedding
and just enjoy it, right?"
- Yeah.
- And just enjoy the wedding.
- Fuck yeah, dude.
- Yeah.
- That sounds nice.
I'm excited for it, man.
- Did you get an
overwhelming amount of people
in your Twitch chat
asking if we were going to Garnt's wedding
or when Garnt's wedding was?
- Yeah.
- As if they were also planning to go.
- They were like, "You're
gonna film it, right?"
I'm like, "No, no."
Why?
- I got that so many times.
People were like,
"So this is a 'Trash
Taste' special, right?"
(all laughing)
It's like the wedding special.
It's like, no!
Could you imagine if I just rocked up
with a fucking camera
being like, all right, so challenge.
- Joey fucking rocks up
with one of the fucking film cameras,
just like, "Yeah, what's going on?"
- We got fucking 10 different video crews
just filming every angle of this wedding.
- GoPro on every corner of the room.
- Connor's got a GoPro on his
fucking forehead like POV.
- Pretty bad, four out
of five, tier list review
of all the free drinks.
- Yeah, I mean-
- Oh my God.
- It was actually,
I barely took any pictures
at the wedding I attended.
Because one, I just felt like,
we have some pictures,
but it was more pictures to
share in between our mates
and you know, we might,
we'll probably share.
- Yeah.
- Me and Sydney will probably
share a few pictures.
- Yeah, you got a wedding
photographer, right?
- Yeah, I don't know how much
we're gonna share to social
media yet, I don't know yet.
It's kind of, I will decide-
- Garnt will be wearing a suit
and Sydney will be wearing a dress,
that's kind of, spoiler alert.
(all laughing)
- And everyone will be nicely
dressed, that's about it.
- It's not gonna be any different
just 'cause we're YouTubers.
We're not like, whoa, wacky!
It's just, I don't know,
it's gonna be a wedding.
- Just a gold play button
in the middle, right?
- That'd be hid.
- Susan comes down, dude.
(all laughing)
Yo, Garnt, dude, really
happy for "Trash Taste."
Really happy for you.
- Susan comes and gives her blessing.
(all laughing)
We say our vows in front of Susan.
- It's just one get out of
demonetization free card.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- I'll take that.
- It's like, just this once.
- Yeah, I don't know,
there have been other YouTubers
who have very much
documented their wedding
and everyone's different
in terms of choosing
how much they wish to share and
it's entirely up to everyone
but you have to understand
that everyone's a bit different
in terms of how much they choose to share.
Because it is a very private event.
- Yeah, you gotta respect the privacy.
- It's a wedding so the way I see about it
is that, I'm only gonna
get one wedding in my life
so how much of this do I
want to share with the world?
How much of this do I want
to keep between myself
and my close mates and family?
I don't know yet.
I'll think about it and we'll decide.
- Content, content, content, content.
- [Garnt] Yeah, 'cause the one-
- You only get one
wedding, Garnt, come on.
- 'Cause you always have
to battle the thought
of you know that whatever you post,
it's gonna get the most engagement-
- Oh yeah.
- Of course, of course!
- That you're ever going to get-
- Of course.
- If I post a video of this,
I know it's gonna get fucking
two, three million views, man.
Easy, easy.
And that's free content, you know?
I don't even have to,
I'm gonna do it anyway,
that's just free content!
- It's like, "Honey, I know
this is a really personal thing
but that click rate through, though."
- What's up, guys, I'm at the altar
with the boys, about to say my vows.
- Seven mid rolls on that shit.
(all laughing)
Whoo! My God.
- Might forward jump into that.
And our sponsor for the day.
(all laughing)
Might be a good place to
actually put it, I don't know.
- Bro, imagine if we
fucking livestream that.
Imagine the fucking Super Chats, man.
- IRL.
- VTubers could dream of
getting the Super Chats-
- Oh my God.
- We would get
at the wedding, man.
- Please, Garnt will not say his vows
until we get at least two grand.
(all laughing)
We are not moving from this spot...
- Yeah, are you excited to go,
are you guys excited to
go to England, though?
'Cause-
- Yeah.
- It's gonna be your second
time in England, right?
- Second time.
- First one didn't count.
First one doesn't count.
- What do you mean?
- You barely saw anything.
- Yeah, you were there for how long?
- I don't even remember.
Five days, I think?
Not even a week, I don't think.
- Take you to a good
Wetherspoons this time.
- Yeah, you took me to-
- A shit one.
- Arguably one of the shittiest ones.
- It was probably the
shittest Wetherspoons.
- Yeah.
- Take you to a good one.
- You still haven't taken me to fucking...
You still haven't given
me a Tesco meal deal
or anything like that.
- Oh, we'll do that too.
I thought maybe, should
I do a tier list video?
I probably shouldn't say that on camera
'cause then people will now expect it.
I want to do a meal deal tier list.
- [Joey and Garnt] A meal deal tier list.
- Of the optimum thing.
'Cause someone, we spoke about.
Wait, did we speak
about it on the episode?
No, no, we didn't.
- Not sure.
- Can't remember.
Oh fuck it, I won't speak about it.
Fuck, what am I gonna say now then?
(all laughing)
- [Garnt] Meal deal tier list.
- I'll do a meal deal tier list.
- How many meal deals are there?
- Combination's are endless, Joey.
- [Joey] Really?
- Endless.
- Damn.
- There's quite a lot actually.
And depending on which stores
you go to, different things.
So it's really-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that what the
wedding food's gonna be?
- I love how Garnt's like,
my wedding, my wedding.
I'm like, yo, the meal deal combinations,
though, it's gonna...
- Let me show you about that.
- That's what's gonna be
at Garnt's wedding, right?
Garnt's like,
"You can choose any Tesco
meal deal you want, baby."
- Everyone else is gonna get
a nice, fancy five-course meal
and on Connor's desk, we're
just gonna give him a meal deal.
- Meal deal.
- I'll be like, you're all
clowns, you're all clowns.
This is worth five pound retail.
I got it for three pound 50.
Mic fell down, bro.
He's like, yo, you get a meal deal, what?
- No, I'm excited though, 'cause-
- We'll take you to Greggs as well.
Yo, you gotta go Greggs.
- What's Greggs again?
- Pasties.
- Oh, the pasties place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I gotta try this,
I gotta try these pasties.
I mean, like, 'cause we're
probably gonna be there-
- [Connor] Pasties, pasties.
- A little longer now,
at least a week and a bit
so I'm planning, hopefully
for Connor to take me to Wales.
- Yeah, we'll see if we can do that.
I don't know if I can do that.
- We'll see if we can do that.
- I told my parents, I was
like, yeah, maybe I'll see you.
Maybe.
- Yeah, maybe.
- We'll see, we'll see.
- Yeah.
- Wales is fun though.
- 'Cause otherwise, let's be real,
I'm never gonna go to Wales otherwise.
- Beautiful place.
- It'll be the only chance, right?
- Exactly.
- It'll be the only chance.
- Amazing hiking in Wales.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause you guys are gonna be there
and a lot of other people
are gonna be flying in as well
so it's gonna be really busy.
I guess to the days leading up
and the even days that you fly in.
- Yeah, honestly.
- I'm hype, though.
- Yeah.
- I'm hype.
- Should be good.
- It's gonna be way more packed
than your last trip to England, I think.
'Cause I can't remember,
why did you come to your
last trip to England?
I can't remember.
- 'Cause Aki and I were already in Europe.
- Oh, that's it.
- Because we went to a con in Finland
and we were just like, "Let's
just go on a Europe tour."
- Yeah.
- So and then, yeah, the
last stop was the UK.
'Cause we were like,
"Yeah, I've never been
to the UK, weirdly,"
even though I have a lot
of mates who live there.
- Yeah.
- It was good though.
Brighton was cool.
I liked Brighton.
- Brighton's a cool city.
- I like Brighton.
Mid, mid.
- We'll have a
lad's night out there.
- Mid city.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause Kevin's been fucking
messaging me every day
about how keen he is for a lad's night
and I'm just like, "Okay, Kevin."
- He's always keen for a lad's night out.
- He's always keen for a lad,
Kevin, when aren't you
keen for a lad's night?
Let's be honest, Kevin.
(Garnt chuckling)
But yeah, I mean,
did you get to see a
lot of London last time?
Because I don't know-
- Not really.
- No, 'cause he was in
Brighton most of the time.
- Yeah.
- You were in Brighton
for most of the time
and I don't know
if you showed him any
of London, that's all.
- London's hard to-
- You took us to a bunch of the,
well, I mean you, 'cause Aki's parents
were there as well, right?
- Yeah.
- So you took us to all of
the touristy places, I guess.
- Yeah.
Luckily London is really
convenient for tourist stuff
where they put everything
really close together.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you can smash it all out
in a day.
- Yeah.
- Right.
I don't know, with
London, it's kind of hard
if you don't drink.
- The only place I remember
was you took us to the
"Harry Potter" place,
the King's Cross, whatever it is.
- Yeah, the Platform 9
3/4 where you run into it.
- It's so weird taking
people to King's Cross
because I just see it as a train station.
- It is.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and it is.
'Cause I think how people imagine it
is just going to the "Harry Potter" land
in Universal Studios or something, right?
Where you have fucking Diagon Alley,
they serve you whatever the beer is there.
- The butterbeer.
- Butterbeer or whatever.
And it's not, it's just one-
- [Connor] Cart in the wall.
- One half cut out train trolley
and a shop
and then the rest of it is
just a fucking normal station.
- It's pretty busy, though.
- It is really busy.
- It's always busy.
- Yeah, it's always busy.
- Luckily, they put it out
of the way of the station
so if you're gonna get a train,
you don't actually go near it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But there's a pub
behind it that sometimes,
I don't know why I've been to it
but it's kind of annoying to,
you've gotta get through all the tourists.
- Is it "Harry Potter" themed at all
or is it just a regular pub?
- No, it's a normal
pub, it's a normal pub.
- No, it's just a normal pub.
- Very normal pub.
- Yeah.
- It's a pub though.
I do miss pubs, actually.
I can't wait to go to the pub again.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That's what I've been missing.
That's it, really.
- Yeah, I will say,
England has definitely
upped up their bar game
since I've been away.
- Okay.
- Yeah, there's a lot more gaming bars
and themed bars as well.
- Yeah.
- Anything's better than the
gaming bar you guys took me to.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I went to a better one
when I was back last time and it was good.
It's just, again, really expensive.
Really, really expensive.
- I mean, that's the price you pay.
I guess, literally that's
the price you pay for the-
- We live in a society.
(all laughing)
- For the-
- What a price to pay.
- For the upscale of just themed bars
and everything like that
'cause I know we've
complained about it before
on "Trash Taste"
and I remember this time
we also celebrated a birthday as well
and Sydney's maid of honor,
I say maid of honor
because her maid of
honor is actually a guy.
He booked this very weird, not weird,
but it was a themed bar
where it was basically a cowboy themed bar
but it's not just a themed bar,
it was a whole experience.
It feels like I'm undermining it
just calling it a themed bar
so you go in and it's like
you just woke up in the South,
Southern America during deep,
when was the cowboy fucking years?
I don't remember.
- 1800s?
- Like 1800s?
Yeah, I don't know.
Basically "Westworld."
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's basically "Westworld."
Everyone's talking in a Southern accent
and they have this,
basically it's like bring
your own booze, right?
And what they do is they take your booze,
whatever you choose to bring
and then they will make
whatever drinks is suitable
with all of the booze that you brang.
So you don't even buy alcohol there,
you get served alcohol there
based on what you bring
and you get taken in
and everyone's a cowboy
and then suddenly a sheriff walks in
and then there's this
whole fucking storyline
that's going on.
It's like, you know-
- I just wanna get drunk.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They serve you fucking
moonshine down a back alley
and all this stuff.
And it's this entire
experience, entire storyline
that you get put into
that is basically just a bar experience.
- This sounds a like
Universal Studios ride.
- It kind of is!
It kind of is except with-
- Except they serve you booze.
- Except with a lot of alcohol.
Oh my God.
I got, because-
- That's awesome.
- Because you bring your own booze there
and there's no limit or
there's no regulation
for what you have to bring there.
- Yeah.
- You mix a lot of fucking drinks there.
So you end up getting very drunk
and then you wake up
and you're just seeing
a bunch of fucking
cowboys go at each other.
And you're like, "Where the fuck am I?
I'm in the middle of London right now."
It's so fucking weird.
I gotta take you guys there, actually.
- It just sounds like a challenge.
- That sounds so strange.
- To bring all your own booze, right?
And then it's just like,
I guarantee there's been instances
where just someone just brings in bottles
of just nothing but hard liquor.
- [Connor] Probably.
- Just puts it on the thing
and just be like, "Make it."
(all laughing)
- Just vodka, make me a drink.
- What you gonna do?
- So yeah, there is a lot more choice now
in terms of just interesting
bars, bar experiences.
It's definitely leveled up.
- Yeah, London seems to be changing a lot.
- It is changing a lot.
Brighton's changing a lot as well.
I hardly even recognize the
city I grew up in anymore
just because it's become
this hip modern place.
And it's gone to the point where,
you know you go to some American
bars or some bars abroad
and you just think, yeah, man,
every bar needs its thing.
So I went to this, I was
just perusing Brighton.
And then there was just this
bar with a zip liner on it
or a zip line on it.
I'm just like, that's the weirdest gimmick
I've ever seen.
- Yeah.
- But, fuck, I wanna go on it, man.
- Wait, a zip liner going out of the bar
or a zip liner going into the bar?
- A zip line going out of the bar.
So basically there is a bar
which just shows, in the UK,
any gimmick can work if
there's a bar next to it.
So I think what happened, right
is they built the zip
line on the sea front
and so there's a zip line,
so you can climb up and
you can zip line down and-
- Sounds like a dangerous
combination with alcohol.
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah, you can see the
beach and everything.
And then on the bottom of the
zip line, there's just a bar.
So it's just now the bar
with the zip line on it.
- So people literally just zip line
into the seat of the bar, just like.
- No, no, no, no.
You start off in the bar
and you can buy tickets
to go on the zip line
and just zip line down to the
opposite side of the beach
or something like that.
- Jesus.
- And that's the bar.
That's just the bar.
- Fair enough.
- To be fair, I would probably go on that.
- Yeah, yeah, right?
- I would probably do that,
that sounds really fun.
- Just shows in the UK,
if you wanna come up
with a concept for a bar,
just come up with a wacky concept.
Doesn't matter what it is.
- Go karts.
- Yeah.
- With alcohol.
- Just put some-
- They serve you
while you're on the go.
- Just put some activity and alcohol
and British people will come to it.
- Yeah, that's yeah
fairly accurate, I'd say.
Pretty spot on.
- Yeah, so, so yeah.
I'm excited for you to come,
I'm excited for you guys to
come back to London this time
because there is a lot more to do now, so.
- That's good.
- I'm sure we can plan
out a lot more fun things
for you to do, Joey.
- Oh yeah.
- I can't remember what
I showed you last time.
I took you to Devil's Dyke, which is-
- Oh yeah!
Which is still one of the
most questionably named places
I've ever been to.
It's basically, it's just a hill.
- It's just a hill.
- It's a really nice hill.
That's about it.
I was just laughing the entire way
when I found out what it
was called and I was like,
they really didn't think that one through.
- English is a funny language.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- English is a very funny language.
- That was a nice place,
that was a nice drive.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's about it really.
- That's about it.
I can't remember.
I can't remember
'cause you didn't stay
in the UK for that long.
- No.
- I don't remember.
- I mean, we also drank at Brighton beach
and stuff like that.
But other than that, that's about it.
- What have you been up to, Joey?
Since Garnt has been gone?
- A lot of stuff I can't talk about yet.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- But I hung out with Nano the other day.
- Oh, yeah. I saw that.
- Oh, nice.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, nice.
- She wanted to hang out
and we went to karaoke
and apparently she hasn't
gone to karaoke in 15 years.
- What?
- Well that's her life.
- She sings for a job.
- I get it, but still, I
mean, it's unavoidable.
- Yeah, right?
- She just goes to karaoke on stage
and in the studio, right?
- And then she sang,
and then we got, we sang a bunch of songs
and then I was like, "Can
you sing one of your songs?"
Just jokingly.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- 'Cause she has her songs on karaoke
so I was like, "You have
to seize that opportunity."
- Of course, of course.
- And she's like,
"I've never sung my own
songs at karaoke before."
And so I thought that was gonna be a no.
That was a nice way of her saying no.
She then proceeds to put
in literally every song.
- You're like, "Oh, I got a concert."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Maybe-
- I basically just got a free concert.
- Maybe no one asked her before.
- No one had the gall.
- Who asked? No one.
- She's like, "I've been waiting
for someone to ask me this
my entire life, Joey."
- Yeah, the audacity of this guy to ask.
Nah, but she was really fucking cool
and we got to hang out
and we're gonna hang out a lot more.
- Yeah.
- Other than that, I've just been, yeah,
every day I've just been hanging
out with someone different.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
- That's always fun though.
- Nice.
- Just going out
and yeah, it's been good.
It's being sociable
again after the pandemic
has been really nice.
- Yeah, right. No kidding.
- Have you had a chance
to hang out with Aki a lot
because there's a lot of
things we can't talk about,
but one thing I will say
is that Joey didn't get to
see a lot of Aki last month.
- No, I think I saw her-
- Like not at all.
- For a week, maybe,
so she was like, "Yeah, let's
hang out a little more,"
and I was like, "Yeah, we
should probably do that."
- That's like a-
- I did, I did though.
I did.
We hung out a lot.
We go on once a week dates
just to nearby places
and hang out and stuff
and yeah, it's really good.
- Oh yeah?
- I've discovered a lot of Tokyo
in this past week, I think.
- Really?
- Just because I've been going out
to all sorts of different places
with all sorts of different people.
So it's like, there's like,
I was in Shibuya just yesterday
for my friend, Luke's birthday.
And we went to all these new
places I'd never been before.
We were in areas of
Shibuya where I was like,
"Oh, this is"-
- Yeah, Shibuya's huge.
- "This exists."
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah, it's
got really cool bars.
- And it's just so weird
that Tokyo's just one of those places
where everything is just so tight knit.
- Yeah.
- And kind of hidden
that there are just entire areas of cities
you've probably never seen before.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you're just like,
"Oh, oh, this place exists.
And this is kind of cool, yeah."
- My Google Maps is fucked
'cause I've saved so many
restaurants and bars I liked.
None of them mean anything now
because I don't know which one is which.
- You literally have to fucking-
- Yeah, when I'm trying to remember a bar,
I'm like, there's no search function
so I'm literally, I'm like,
I think it was this area
and I'm just checking all
my hearts in that area
and I'm like, "Okay, great,
it's not a fucking,
it's great, I'm fucked."
There's no way to categorize.
- I've actually started doing that now
'cause I didn't do that before but because
when you go to so many different places
and you're trying to recall
that one place in Tokyo.
- [Connor] Right, right, right, right.
- It's like the hardest fucking city
'cause in most other cities,
you can be like, "What is this bar?"
And you type in the
description of the bar.
You're like, "Great, there's
only one bar in this area.
It's five minutes away."
You type in the vague description in Tokyo
and seven different bars pop up
and you're like, "It was
one of these, I think.
I don't even know if I'm
describing it right."
- Yeah.
- You know?
- It's great 'cause when Emily
and Daidus just moved here,
it's like, all right,
what food do you want?
I have a thing for that.
Oh, what kind of bar vibe do you want?
All right, I've got three of each kind.
Oh, we're in this area?
Okay, we'll go to this one.
I have a thing.
I've saved everything so I've
got every kind of restaurant,
every kind of vibe you'd want.
- Yeah.
- So I've got a bunch.
So it's fantastic.
- But it's become so extensive now
that you're just like,
"Okay, so you're going for a
specific vibe, specific food,
I know eight places."
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which one of these
eight places do you want?
- Yeah, and then it's like, "All right,
how expensive do you want?"
Okay, (indistinct), do you wanna be
a five-minute walk from the station,
10-minute walk from the station?
Okay, we're gonna go to
this bar afterwards though,
is that okay with you?
And then it's like, all right, okay, okay.
But I'm still trying to find more as well.
- Yeah.
- So many places, I'll
never get to see them all.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, yeah,
even just in Shibuya,
there's just so many places
to just eat or drink out
that you could-
- Oh yeah, Shibuya's-
- You could go out every night to a bar.
- Yeah.
- Somewhere different
just in Shibuya and it'll
probably take you years.
- Yeah.
One thing I definitely noticed
going back to the UK
for two weeks that I did
is that I've definitely taken for granted
how easy it is to find somewhere
to stay out late in Japan.
- Ha ha ha ha, yeah.
- I've forgotten about
that in the UK 'cause-
- It hits 12 and it's impossible.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it hits 12 and every
bar closes, every pub closes,
so the only place that you
can vibely go to basically,
is a club.
And most of the time, I don't
wanna go clubbing, you know?
I don't wanna go to a club.
I wanna continue the
conversation I'm having.
So I've definitely
gotten used to in Japan,
you hit up the karaoke
or there's this one bar
that's open till 4:00 a.m.,
or there's so many places open till late.
And I've forgotten that
in the UK, it hits 12
and you try to Google where
the next place to go to is.
And there's nothing,
there is just nothing.
You just come out blank and
you're like, "Well, fuck,
we gotta keep this going somehow, right?"
- Yeah.
- And there's just no options
available, unfortunately.
- Yeah, the UK sucks for that.
I do remember that.
- Yeah.
- Every night at 12 it's
like, all right, fuck,
we have to really look to find a place.
- Yeah.
- It's just like someone
went to the power bank
and just went pew.
Everything just goes
down like an apocalypse.
- Well yeah, on Sundays
shops shut at 4:00 p.m.
- What?
What, just supermarkets?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Or some places just don't even open.
- Oh, I mean, I get the don't even open
but what's the point of
being open for five hours?
- I think London has laws of on Sunday,
a shop can only remain
open for X amount of hours
so they choose the busiest hours
from 10 til 4:00.
- Oh, I see.
- I can't remember what
the exact hours were
but I know at least,
where I lived in London, it was that rule.
So all the shops shut and opened
at the same time on Sundays.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's kind of
been like that right now.
With it being Golden Week in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And when I was hanging out with Nano,
we were trying to find a lunch place.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it's either it's
closed during Golden Week.
- Right.
- Or it's got 200% capacity.
- Yeah.
If you come to Japan,
try and avoid this period
'cause hotels and flights
and everything is doubled.
- Oh my God, I saw
pictures of Haneda Airport-
- Oh God.
- This week.
It is a nightmare.
- Yeah, 'cause it's
basically the only week off
that most working Japanese people have,
where they have a full week off.
- Yeah.
- So they all travel,
they all go to hotels.
So yeah, try and avoid this
week if you come to Japan.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's rammed.
- It is.
- It's the week where every
manga chapter takes a week off.
That's how you know, that's how
I remember what Golden Week-
- Is it actually that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause I remember growing up
and being like, "Man, 'Naruto,'
'One Piece,' and 'Bleach'
are taking a break on the same week?
What's going on? What's going on?
I need to know what's happening, man."
- That's how manga readers tell the time.
They're like, "Oh, 'Ode'
is taking a week off,
must be Golden Week."
(all laughing)
- [Connor] True.
- Yeah, 'cause it's not only
that bars close as well.
I forget, combinis are a thing here
so if you need access to alcohol
if you're going round a
mate's house, whatever,
you've always got the combini.
- Yeah.
- But you wanna go
to a Tescos or a Sainsbury's or something,
you better hope that you plan ahead
and you get it before 11, which is,
some places close at 11
and that's the latest some places close.
It's just.
- And you pay double the price of alcohol
'cause you're at a corner
store that's shitty
and they make all their money
from upcharging alcohol.
- Yeah.
- But even, there are some
corner stores you go to,
especially in London
where you know, it's open,
but they don't serve alcohol past 12.
- Oh.
- So it's like, "Well, fuck, man."
You literally have no options, so.
- But I discovered that the other day
when I was coming home late and
it was last train and stuff.
And I was like, "Oh man,
feeling a bit hungry.
Might just pop over to a McDonald's,
just do a quick little
Maccas run before I go."
And it was 1:00 a.m., right?
And the McDonald's are still open.
I was like, "Oh, sick,
amazing. Let's go in."
So I walk in and the
guy's like, "Drink only."
- [Connor] What?
And I was like, "Who the fuck
is walking into a McDonald's
to get a drink?"
- No, look, I'll close
the sign for you, bro.
Let me close the sign.
- Yeah, literally, why are you open?
- Shut it down, dude, shut it down.
- It's like, I could just go to a combini.
- Yeah, that's so stupid.
- Bro, who's going to a...
- Who's going to a McDonald's being like,
"One Sprite, please"?
- At 1:00 a.m. as well, right.
- At 1:00 a.m., like.
- How much money are they
making from the drinks
to warrant staying open only for drinks?
- I mean, I thought it was a bit weird
being like, oh, okay, it's still open
but there's no one in here right now.
- Yeah.
- Sus, dude.
- Now I know.
- Sus.
- Man, you don't know
your target audience
if you're at 1:00 a.m.
and you're serving drinks only.
What the fuck?
- There isn't a special drink
that's only served at
McDonald's, you know.
- Mate, there's only one reason
I'm going to McDonald's at 1:00 a.m.,
it's to smash a fucking-
- Yeah, it's like, give
me a fucking burger.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I wanna smash a burger.
- Smashing a burger or
ordering those 20 nugs
which you would never
order except at 1:00 a.m.
at a McDonald's, you know?
- I'm not here to smash an
orange juice at a McDonald's
at 1:00 a.m., yeah?
I can do that anywhere.
- I always get the milk.
- Milk?
- Yeah, I just get the milk.
- I only exclusively
drink McDonald's milk.
- I go there for milk, that's it.
- Ronald's milk.
- Why do you go there for milk?
- I don't, no.
I used to order it,
though, it was all right.
Tastes like shit.
(all laughing)
I don't know why I-
- How do you fuck up milk?
- I don't know, man, Ronald, man.
Ronald's secret sauce.
- [Joey] Ronald's fresh squeeze.
- I haven't really been up to much either.
I've kinda just been working.
I've been to barbecue
a bunch, that was fun.
Barbecuing was chill.
- Nice.
- It was nice. It was raining though.
- How's the weather been here?
Oh, I guess I was gonna,
literally you answered my question
as I was processing what I was going say.
- So this place I stayed at
had a place outside where
you could still barbecue
even if it was raining
'cause it was covered.
- Right.
- So that was fun.
And it was, yeah, it was fun.
I like barbecuing.
- It's a good time for
barbecuing right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it's just just warming up.
- Weather was nice.
- Yeah.
- So that was chill.
Got to do that. That was fun.
I just smelled of smoke for three days.
It's fun.
And then we had a bonfire
and then it was very fun
'cause you just keep adding
and we had to chop our own wood as well.
That was fun.
- Oh, that's fun.
- Just camping vibes again.
- Yeah, it's very nice.
'Cause we had-
- Did you have an ax and everything?
- It was a hammer and there was a thing
where you put the log on
and it was like a metal thing like this.
- Oh nice, nice.
- And you smack it into it.
- [Garnt] Oh, cool.
- Could just hear the, I don't know,
the dwarf for music from
"Lord of the Rings" in my head
just while I was smacking away.
Just like bring me another log.
Do do do do do.
- As you were chopping and
your beard just extensively-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(indistinct)
- Should have put one of those lumberjack-
- Yeah, I should have, I was like,
"Yeah, dude, this is what it's all about."
They're bringing my logs over like this.
I'm like, "All in the fire we go."
- The red and black
checkered shirt, you know?
- It was so fun.
I don't know why chopping wood was so fun.
- Your hair just turns red.
(all laughing)
- I definitely-
- It's like, oh, I'm a ginger now.
- Definitely am a monkey, dude.
Just like smacking it was fun.
- Yeah, dude, it's the best feeling.
- So fun.
- I feel like there's just
something primal about that.
- Yeah, I just went to Costco before
and bought a bunch of
food and barbecued it
and I bought way too much food.
'Cause it was really hard to eat it all.
- I mean, it is Costco, right?
- I know, I know,
it was so much food, but
it was so fucking good.
It was so delicious.
Barbecuing, I love barbecuing.
- Yeah.
- How long were you there for?
- Three days, so pretty chill.
- Oh, nice.
- Pretty chill.
- That's nice.
- It was nice to relax, get away.
- Yeah.
- And just chill for a bit
before I guess I'm gonna go away again,
but it's just 'cause this
next two, three weeks
are just all work.
So, and then going back to the UK.
- Yeah.
- Have a little bit of work.
- Yeah, like-
- Weddings and stuff.
- I'm trying to pack as much as I can
before I fly back to the UK.
- [Connor] Right, right, right, right.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's definitely,
I was like, yeah,
I can work at home.
I have a dedicated office
where I can work and stuff
if I need to.
But it's just something
about being out of Japan.
My body's just like, "You
are in holiday mode now."
- Yeah.
- Why do you need to work?
People are out.
People want to see you.
- I'm telling myself I'll be like,
I'll have a bit of time in
the UK to do some stuff.
I could probably just sneak it in.
I know though, the moment
I get there, I'm just like,
"Yeah, so, pub, pub?"
- I wanna livestream
but I just feel like
I'm gonna be stream sniped
into oblivion in London.
If I'm drinking at a pub, people-
- Yeah.
- It could be fun though.
- "Trash Taste" is definitely,
it's definitely changed
things for me in the UK
in terms of-
- Yeah, I was about to ask,
how much were you recognized in the UK?
Compared to before?
- A lot.
I don't, like the fucking,
at this wedding I went to,
the bartender was a fan
of "Trash Taste," right?
(all laughing)
- No way.
- That's awesome.
- Mates rates, mates rates.
- Mates rates.
And fucking Sydney cajoled him
to giving him a free drink
because she was like, "You recognize him
but you don't recognize me?
How dare you, how dare you!"
(all laughing)
- Well, you're not fucking
Sydney's "Trash Taste,"
what the fuck's she on about?
(Garnt laughing)
- She managed to get a free drink.
She's literally been on the show one time
and she's like, "I'm the one
who was on 'Trash Taste.'"
- Do you know who I am?
I am getting married to him, actually.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- So I am basically also "Trash Taste."
- She was also very
intoxicated at this time,
as we all were.
But no, but yeah, because
Brighton has become, I guess-
- Oh, it's a YouTuber city for the-
- The influencer city.
It's so weird.
I can't, sometimes I'll just
be sitting at my local pub
which I won't say but it is my local pub
so it is within the
vicinity in which I live
and it's very nerve-wracking
whenever I get recognized there
because one, it's weird to go
to the pub that you grew up in
and that you always went
to and you grew up there.
And now you go there
and sometimes, the odd person
just recognizes you from "Trash Taste."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it's always "Trash Taste."
It's all like-
- Yeah.
- It's all "Trash Taste."
So sometimes people recognize me,
even though I got the mask on
when I'm walking in Brighton.
It's super super surreal
because obviously it's
the place I grew up in.
And now it's become
this really hip, happening
influencer city, you know?
- It's basically the LA of UK
when it comes to YouTubers.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, definitely, definitely.
So there's actually,
I think I got recognized
more in Brighton per se,
than I did in London
'cause London's a bit more spread out.
It's a bit more-
- [Connor] Yeah, it's (indistinct)
- It's a bit more dispersed.
I do get recognized the
odd place in London,
but definitely in Brighton,
it's way more concentrated.
Whenever I go to the city center,
there's normally one or two people
that recognizes me from "Trash Taste."
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's cool.
- Probably be the same
for you guys as well.
- Maybe.
I blend in really well though.
(all laughing)
So.
- Can't quite say the same thing for me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's gonna be interesting
because we haven't really,
since "Trash Taste" started,
we haven't really had that yet, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you know, the
borders have been closed here
so not as many foreigners coming to Japan.
I mean, a little more recently I'd say.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but the past month or
so I've been like, "Oh."
- Yeah, I got recognized twice-
- There's a lot of white people around.
- Twice in one day the other day.
- Oh, really?
- Oh, nice.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've noticed there's
a lot more people now.
- Whereabouts?
- Shinjuku.
- Oh, okay.
Well that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So that was like, I was
like, "Whoa, that's weird."
This is happening a lot more.
- Yeah.
Because people are coming in now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They've made it a lot
easier to get in the country.
At least my experience was.
This time I spent an hour
and a half in the airport
as opposed to four hours-
- That's good.
- Which was nice.
- Yeah.
- Which is nice.
- That's really nice.
- The first thing I noticed
is that they removed
the fucking cattle tag
that they give everyone.
- Oh, thank God.
- So I didn't feel like livestock,
which was a nice positive.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I can't imagine if you're
waiting for years to come in
on your work VISA.
Finally, the fucking country opens
and the first thing they do is
tag you like fucking cattle.
- Brand you.
- Fucking brand you, you know?
So, you know-
- Welcome to Japan, tss.
- Thank God they've removed that system.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Everything's just a
lot more streamlined now.
And I mean, it's a lot easier
traveling outside of the country as well.
I mean, England,
I didn't even-
- Thank God.
- Need to get tested
or give a vaccine certificate or anything.
It's just back to normal, right?
- Geez.
- God bless the queen, eh?
Jesus Christ.
It's kinda crazy.
- Yeah.
- Hopefully it lasts
'cause the one thing I'm
really fucking worried about
is while we're overseas,
say at Garnt's wedding,
and then they'll just,
discovered a new strain, guys.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Let's go.
You know?
- Feel like even if they do,
people are gonna be like, "No."
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I don't think so.
- Well the one thing that I am,
I don't know if I'm looking forward to
or dreading is the next
convention we go to.
- 'Cause shit, we can't
announce what it is yet.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We are going to a convention.
- We're going to several conventions
but I remember what it was
like before "Trash Taste."
I can't imagine what going to a convention
is going to be like after "Trash Taste."
- Yeah, conflu was always a thing,
and now it's like conflu
on steroids is a thing now.
- Yeah, one thing we've
definitely had to plan around
that we've never needed to
do before in conventions
is planning what we're doing
and the events we're going to
is that technically, we
are now a fire hazard.
- Yeah.
- In some conventions.
- At some conventions,
we are now a fire hazard.
So that's something that I
never had to think about before.
- Yeah.
- There was people asking,
"Do you want security?"
And I'm like, "Oh, that feels so weird."
- Yeah.
- Do I really want
a guy just following me around?
But then I guess I don't wanna get hurt,
but I mean, it feels weird, I don't know.
- Yeah, it does.
- It definitely feels weird
'cause it's definitely a
different kind of planning
than any of the conventions
I've been to before.
- 'Cause I've always seen,
there's been a couple of big guests
at conventions I've been to, right?
That have security guards and security.
And I was just like, "Look at this guy."
- Big dick on campus here.
- Look at this guy, oh the big
dick brigade coming through.
And now I'm about to be that guy.
And I don't know how to feel about that.
- Because I don't wanna be like,
"Guys, I don't need all this extra shit.
Come on, guys, come on, guys.
I'm just a guy, I'm just a guy."
But at the same time,
especially being back this time,
being like, I can't even
walk down my local street.
How's it gonna be
where all of the weebs
and all of the people
that are interested in your content
and your content field are
going to be concentrated
in one place
and I'm just like, that's pretty scary
now that I think about it.
I've never-
- It's pretty cool though.
I mean, I'm excited-
- It's gonna be cool.
- I haven't seen it in a while.
I'm excited to see what it-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think the last fan meetup
I had, I can't remember.
There was a decent amount of
people that showed up to it
so I don't even know
if I can even a do a fan meetup this time.
- Yeah, yeah, I was talking to Alan
and he was just like, "Yeah,
remember when you used to do
unofficial fan meetups?"
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I don't think
that's happening this time
and I'm just like, "Yeah,
because it is a fire hazard."
Or that has to be taken into account
when we do any kind of meetups now.
How are we gonna arrange
people who come to see us?
And are we blocking anything
that could potentially be
a health and safety hazard?
- It sucks though 'cause I miss-
- Don't wanna piss off
the convention people.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It sucks though
'cause I used to do those
kinds of casual fan meetups
every now and then with
Aki and I miss that shit.
- I miss that shit as well.
- It's 'cause it's so chill.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's like, you
know, you just tweet out
being like, "Hey, we're gonna
be here for a couple of hours.
If you wanna hang out,
just come hang out."
And it's usually 50 people max
and that's a sizeable amount
to be like, yeah, okay, you know what?
This is-
- Yeah, this is-
- This is kinda chill.
- 'Cause you can talk to people.
(speakers drown each other out)
- You can talk to everyone,
you can have a conversation with people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Interesting to hear
where people have come from
and why they've come-
- Yeah!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've met so many cool
people through that
and now it just sucks that, yeah.
It's a fire hazard now.
- Now it's an Indian wedding.
- And now it's an Indian wedding.
- So now here's the stray,
if you see me outside of the convention,
you can talk to me.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Exactly, exactly.
- But that's like playing gotcha.
- That's luck.
(speakers drown each other out)
You'll probably never see
me outside of a convention
'cause I don't leave my room
but maybe if you do, we
can talk a little bit.
Unless I'm in a rush, then
I'll be like, "Sorry."
- Because then it's always that instance
of if someone recognizes you
in those kinds of outside
convention settings.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- All it takes is for one person
to be like, "Oh my God, Connor!"
For everyone to just fucking
whip their heads around
and then a crowd gets forward.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Conventions when those crowds of people
normally wanna see what the crowd's about.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So, yeah, it's pretty bad.
- I remember the worst I saw it before
was you at the Singaporean Convention
where it was like traveling
next to fucking Justin Bieber.
We had this-
- That was pretty crazy, yeah.
- We had panels to go to
and I remember it was just like,
you could not take two
steps without being stopped.
- Yeah.
- And-
- That was the first time
I had to get security.
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
- And I was like-
- Did you get security?
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
- I had to because the
con was literally like,
"If you keep going, you're
gonna be a fire hazard."
- Yeah.
And so I was like, "This is cool,
but also really fucking weird."
- Yeah, a fire hazard.
But just because you're
blocking walkways or something,
it's not like it's a big deal
but if you're-
- It's not like someone's
there with a fucking match.
- But 'cause people are stopping, right
so if you just stop in
a hallway or something,
it's technically a fire hazard
and a lot of the venues can be punished
if it gets shown around
that that's happening.
- You know, 10 people stop,
that's fine, that's manageable,
50 people stop, you're kind of-
- Not ideal, but-
- You're kind of getting
in the way of people.
If 100, 200 people stop,
then you are stopping the
flow of people walking about.
You're causing literal.
I was gonna call it human traffic.
But is there a word?
- You are human traffic.
- You are human trafficking right now.
(all laughing)
I don't know what the
word is or the term is
but it's basically-
- Human traffic jam.
- A human traffic jam, I guess.
- I went to a convention.
I think you went to the same one.
I won't name it just in
case they get annoyed
that apparent, one year
they had Markiplier at the convention.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And apparently this
is the first convention
that Markiplier ever did.
It was in the States.
- I know which con
you're talking about, yeah.
- And they spoke about this
like it was the zombie apocalypse, dude.
Because apparently,
right, what happened was
is that, you know, I think
some, did Jacksepticeye go too?
- One of the years, I think, yeah.
- I remember it was a really
big, big fucking deal.
And the convention runners didn't,
they knew YouTube and they
knew that it was a big deal,
but they didn't quite understand.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- How big of a deal it was.
So they were woefully unprepared.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- For Markiplier's audience.
And apparently they were
just like, it was insane.
- Yeah.
- The security barriers,
they didn't have anything really.
- Yeah.
- And so,
apparently it was stampedes.
People were just getting hurt.
And they had one security
guy for 1,000 people
when only 100 people should have turned up
and they didn't plan, you know?
And they had, 'cause
they'd paid, I don't know,
God knows amount of
money for that one extra
in that one Marvel movie.
And they were like,
"Well, he's the big deal,
he was in a Marvel movie."
So it's kinda like they
just didn't get it.
And apparently it was
an absolute nightmare.
- Yeah, they talked about it
as if it was a scene
ripped straight out of
"Dead Rising" or something.
- [Connor] Like "World
War Z" or something.
- Yeah, like "Dead Rising."
It's just like.
- Yeah.
- It was insane, apparently.
- But like-
- Every single time
anything would come up,
they'd be like, "The event
that shall not be named."
(all laughing)
'Cause apparently it was such a disaster
trying to manage this, that they,
the convention, I think
that their reasoning was
that they banned him from coming back.
And it was like,
that sounds like it was
your problem, though.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Interesting.
I don't know, I can't remember exactly.
- How dare you be too popular.
- Yeah, right.
- For our convention.
- I think that's something like,
it was really like they
fucked up massively
and not considered how.
- Well, I think it's events like this
that have thankfully
made events and people
and not just events but
also influencers themselves
know, I know, I know, I
hate the word, I hate it.
- Show off.
- But people like us.
(all laughing)
- We are not the same.
- We're not like those other people!
- No, no, no, 'cause the
reason I talk about it
like YouTubers or TikTokkers or whatever
is that we came from,
we all came from the same place
and we don't wanna feel
like we don't need security,
we don't need to worry about this.
We're like the man of
the people, you know?
But at the same time,
there's been enough incidents
like the Markiplier thing,
like Tanacon, like a lot.
There's been enough other influencers
who have set the precedent
to be like things can go
really, really fucking wrong
if you don't plan shit out
because we know that you wanna
be seen as the casual person,
the same as everyone else
but you do have a massive audience
and it's gotten to the point
where a lot of people need to think
about how did they manage
the audience they have IRL
because you see a number, you
see a number on your YouTube
and you're just like,
"That's 10,000 people,"
or, "That's 100,000 people,
it's just a number."
But when you translate that number,
even if it's just a 10th of the number
you see on your YouTube
channel to real life,
that fills up a-
- That's like a football stadium.
- That's what really sucks
about not going to a convention
at all recently is that we can't tell
'cause you know, it would
slowly ramp up, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We'd go to more convention.
- I have no clue.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what's gonna-
- What our IRL situation is.
- 'Cause normally with how
"Trash Taste" has grown
over the past two years.
Normally we'd get to ramp up
the experience to be like,
"Okay, guys, I think
we're reaching that point
where we need to start
thinking about this,
kind of start thinking about that."
But because it's just been two
years of us talking in Japan,
we have no idea what it's going to be like
when we, I guess return
to the rest of the world
and conventions and stuff like that.
We're just playing a guessing
game a lot of the time
in what we're gonna need and
how we're gonna manage it.
- Last time I went to AX,
I could easily walk through it all.
And there was maybe, I
don't know, 50/50 chance
that someone would recognize me.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And that was when I had what,
400,000 subs or something?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So, and that was before
"Trash Taste," obviously.
- Yeah.
- So that's,
I don't know what it's gonna be like now.
I mean, who knows?
- Yeah, ah, dude.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Not excited for it.
- Well-
- I'm excited-
- I'm excited but dreading.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, oh God,
I don't wanna cause any
problems for anyone.
- It's like equal amounts-
- But I wanna meet everyone!
I wanna say hi to you guys.
- It's equal amounts excitement,
equal amounts terrifying.
- Yeah, yeah.
Same here.
I'm nervous in both ways.
I'm excited to go experience conventions
and just go see the vibe
and everything again.
I'm scared to see how things have changed
after last the two years.
- More so mourning the loss
of my weird convention
stories, probably now.
I don't get to stay in
random Discord Airbnbs
where I met people online-
- All right.
- Yeah.
- That's not gonna happen anymore.
That sucks.
- Sad.
- That was fun, fun stories.
Weird moments in my life.
- He will reminisce as he
sits in his five-star hotel.
- I'm just like you, for real.
(all laughing)
- No, he doesn't miss that, no.
Connor's just like, "Give me
the fucking five-star hotel."
- Give me the Sheraton right now.
- No, it's fun but also
it's like God damn,
that was no way to live.
- It's like damn, bitch,
you live like this?
- I think I got all my really stupid ideas
out of my head and now I'm
trying to be more sensible
and take care of myself and yeah.
- It's time to adult now.
This episode is sponsored by Harry's.
- Boys, you know I've been using Harry's
for a very long time.
- Yes you have.
- It's the only razor I trust
near my beautiful boyish young face.
- And it's become part
of your routine now.
- [Joey] Hasn't it?
- It's become part of my daily routine
'cause it's the only blade that I trust
that'll give me the best shave possible.
- Well then, you'll be happy
to know, Connor and audience
that Harry's is giving their
best offer to you guys.
- Get out of here.
- Right now.
- Get out of it.
- That's right.
First time Harry's customers
can redeem a starter set
for just three dollary doos.
- $3?
- What!
- If you go to harrys.com/trashtaste.
That includes a five blade cartridge.
- Oh my gosh.
- A weighted handle.
- Woo.
- Foaming shave gel.
- Woo!
- And a travel cover
to protect your blades on the go.
A $13 value for just-
- What?
- $3.
- Harry's has the highest
customer satisfaction
in the shaving industry.
I can concur and they're still
offering a no-risk trial.
Don't like your shave?
No worries, it's on them.
So what are you doing?
Get the new look with the
same incredible offer.
There's never really been a better time
to give Harry's a try.
Just go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to get your starter set for just $3.
That's harrys.com/trashtaste.
Back to the episode.
- Okay, well I guess
we've literally got approval from Meilyne
that we can announce actually.
- What are we announcing?
- One place that we're going
is going to be Anime Expo.
- Aah!
- That should have been the obvious one.
I feel like us announcing
Anime Expo is just like,
well of course, of course, that's-
- I also eat food.
(all laughing)
- Yes, I am an anime YouTuber.
- No one knew if it was
even happening this year.
- I mean, I certainly
got fucking bombarded
by my Twitch chat being like,
"You going to Anime Expo? Anime Expo?"
- So if you're going to
AX, you can see us all.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- (indistinct) staff.
I don't know what else.
- We got, hopefully, a bunch
of cool things planned.
- Can we announce, can we
announce the rest of the shit
that we're doing?
- I don't think-
- Not sure yet.
- Okay, okay.
We do have something special.
- There's some cool stuff happening, so.
- We do have, it's not just
gonna be us turning up at AX,
we do have some cool stuff
planned for AX as well.
- So if you're going, we'll see you there.
And if you see me around, say hi.
Buy me a drink and I'll-
- Don't say that, you're gonna be like-
- 200 drinks deep.
- You're gonna be intoxicated.
(all laughing)
- I'm kidding, don't
do that, don't do that.
- What am I gonna do
with all these drinks?
- Don't bring me a drink.
If we're in a bar, then
you can buy me a drink.
- There's gonna just be a
line to the SeaDog VA panel
just be like, here's a
drink, here's a drink.
- It's just like an offering.
- I'm gonna say this now
'cause this always happens.
Please don't bring me food.
It is an absolute nightmare
to try and carry around with me.
I don't want food, don't bring me food.
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm also fat enough,
I don't need anymore.
- Yeah.
- If you do see me
outside of the convention,
buy me drink as well.
As long as I'm not carrying
five drinks at the time.
- I might buy you a drink as well.
- The only food I will accept, however,
is Flamin' Hot Cheetos.
You can bring me as many of those-
- No, no, no, no, no, no
'cause everyone will
bring one, don't say that.
- Yeah, that's exactly what I want.
- Okay, that's-
- Just give it to me.
- That's a Joey thing.
- Bro, his hotel's
gonna be a fucking hot
Cheeto landfill, dude.
It's gonna-
- I'm gonna just open the window
and just throwing fucking
Cheetos to the crowd.
You get some Cheetos.
- Nah, I'm excited, dude.
I'm really hyped.
- Yeah.
- First time in, geez, when
was the last AX we went to?
Three years ago?
- Yeah, it was literally the
last convention I went to.
- February, 'cause it was one of my,
it's always one of my
favorite conventions to go to.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I always get to meet everyone.
- It's not just a convention,
it's basically just like, yeah, it's-
- An AniTuber meetup.
- It is an AniTuber meetup.
- How the British people get
to see the American people.
- [Joey] Pretty much, yeah.
- 'Cause we're all not American.
- Yeah, yeah.
I wonder how many people
are gonna go there this year
in terms of-
- Yeah, don't know.
- Other content creators
and stuff like that.
- Call to action.
- Well, if you're any
content creators going to AX,
hit us up, whatever.
- See you there.
- Yeah, big small-
- [Connor] Yeah, we'll be
in LA as well, so, yeah.
Let us know.
- I wonder if we're gonna have
the annual AniTuber meetup.
'Cause did you guys go to
that last year, last time?
I can't remember.
- I did not.
- Because there's like-
- Where was the last one?
Not the one at the bowling alley.
- There was one at a bowling alley?
- Yeah.
- [Camera Person] Oh
no, that's Funimation.
- Funimation Party.
- You wanna explain what this is?
- Huh?
- Yeah, so every, when did it even start?
I don't even remember when it started.
- I can't remember.
- I think it was five, six
years ago or something,
but as long as I've been to AX,
there's always been one,
but there there's always been
this unofficial AniTuber meetup thing
where basically it used to just be done
outside of the convention hall,
in that open area where
all the cosplays are
and it's just like, it doesn't
matter how big or small
of an AniTuber you are,
you can just come to this
event, kinda meet everyone.
'Cause at the end of the day,
especially five, six years ago,
the AniTuber community was
so fucking small, right?
- Yeah.
- So there'd be 30 people, max.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The last one I went to, though,
there was 100 people.
I was like, oh, it's getting big now.
- It's getting big now.
- Fucking hell.
- I think 'cause that one was like,
people were asking for invites
and then people were asking
them for invites, and-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then there were people there
who definitely weren't
making YouTube videos.
- Yeah.
There were people just showing up.
- And they were just showing up
'cause they knew Gigguk would be there.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- So it was like, I don't know, man.
- Yeah, yeah, I don't know
how it's gonna work nowadays
but there's normally one
AniTuber or something
who has just rented out a house.
- Yeah.
- And that's just now become
the unofficial AniTube meetup.
- Pretty much.
- Well, they just rent out a house
and they just invite a
bunch of people, you know.
- Yeah, that one was chill.
- That one was awesome.
- I enjoyed that one.
But yeah, the last time we did
one outside of the convention
was five years ago, I think.
And there was maybe 50, 60 people there.
Obviously way too many
people to actually meet
and get to know personally, but yeah,
I miss those.
I met a lot of really cool
AniTubers at that event.
I met John for the first time,
Super Eyepatch Wolf there.
- Love seeing John.
- The first time.
- Love hanging out with John.
- He was the crowd favorite that year
because he'd never been to a convention
and never shown his face.
So everyone was like
"Yo, Super Eyepatch Wolf!
Let's go, dude!"
- Yeah.
- Amazing.
- Also,
absolutely chill dude, as well.
- Absolute chill dude, absolute Chad.
He's the mega Chad of AniTube.
In terms of looks.
- Man's got a fucking
jawline and a half, dude.
- Dude, I'm hype, man, I'm really excited
to go to conventions.
I think not being able to see
the viewers for a long time
has made my brain go too YouTuber-y.
I got YouTube brain.
- What do you mean?
What's YouTube brain?
- It's all numbers for me.
- It's all numbers to you.
- It doesn't mean anything to me,
I haven't seen anyone.
- It's just data.
- I haven't left my house.
I just stay in Japan.
Even more isolated.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just wanna be drinking at a bar
and then someone strikes
up a conversation,
being like, "Oh, I love your stuff."
And we just have a nice,
chill conversation.
That's some of my
favorite fan interactions,
because as much as I wanna have
the longer conversations
with people come to meetups,
it's like, yeah, you're in
like Indian wedding head space
where it's just like, you have a,
if you're lucky, a few
minutes with everyone
but when you're just chilling
and that random guy
recognizes you or random girl,
you're just having a nice conversation.
And you're just like, "Ah,
I remember why I started
what I'm doing right now.
It's for moments like this, man."
- I weirdly have a lot of
those though in Japan, I think
because you don't get recognized
as often in Japan,
especially nowadays, right?
So the one person who does
find you on the street,
you actually, as long as
you are not in a rush,
you actually have, at least me, anyway,
I have at least a three or
four-minute conversation
being like, "Oh, you know,
what are you doing here?"
All that kind of stuff.
And those are the best.
- Yeah.
- Those are the best.
- Well, in Japan, it's different
because right now, no one
here is a tourist, right?
So everyone here is doing something
or has an interesting story,
or is working here or
something like that, and-
- Lots of students now.
- Lots of students.
- Now there is lots of students now.
I don't know, 'cause when did they start
letting people in again?
- A month ago?
- Like, a month ago?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I've noticed there's loads more-
- I mean, I've barely been
in Japan for the last month.
How's it been for you guys?
- I did a stream recently
and I got stream sniped
a lot more than last time.
- Right.
- So I think that was interesting.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was fun, though.
- It's definitely gone to
the point now where, again,
I've just noticed, there's
a lot more foreigners now.
And then I just remembered, oh yeah,
there's just a lot more students now.
- Yeah.
- And then obviously, you know,
you have more of a
chance to get recognized.
I was in butt fuck middle
of nowhere the other week
outside of Tokyo.
- Yeah.
- And there was just
two random dudes who just recognized me.
And I was just like,
in my head, I was like,
"This is weird."
But then I was like, "No, this
is what it used to be like."
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So now it's just this weird whiplash
of being like, "Oh, fuck,
we're slowly going back to
normal, finally, hopefully."
- The world is healing.
- It is truly healing.
- Hopefully-
- Shit is healing.
- Rage.
- Yeah, 'cause your plan
is to go back to Australia
this year as well, aren't you?
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go see my family
for the first time in three years.
- Oh my God.
- Fucking hell.
- Well, I mean, the trip
to the UK for your wedding
is the first time I'm gonna be overseas
in three years.
- Deported, dude.
- Yeah, I know, it's-
- Oh yeah, 'cause the last time
you attempted to go overseas,
you got deported, right?
- I got deported.
(Garnt cackling)
And you've been waiting
three years since then.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- It's like PTSD now.
The last time I went on
an international flight,
I got deported, so.
- That's a cool story.
- It is a cool story.
It's a cool story to tell the kids
but, yeah, yeah, I'm going
down to see my family
and mates and stuff like that
so that's gonna be very weird.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Just seeing the city I
grew up in completely change
'cause my sister was saying that, yeah,
it's completely changed
in the past three years.
I'm like, this is gonna be weird.
- It was very weird going
back to my home city
and just seeing it
completely changed as well.
And even just seeing
London slightly changed-
- Well, the skyline of London,
there's loads more skyscrapers now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There was two and now
there's tons more being built.
It's crazy.
I wonder how it managed to
not get them for so long then.
It's pretty strange.
- But now I'm gonna be so
scared of what you experienced
of just being at a place
that's very local and familiar to me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If I go to my local mall,
I'm just gonna be like, "No
one recognize me, please."
Not here, don't follow me home, please.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I was worried about, yeah.
- God.
- Be like, "Come in my
house for some tea."
- Meet my parents.
- Have some crumpets and
biscuits, come on, come on.
- Yeah, London's become very bougie.
I called an Uber, it was
my first Uber in London-
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
And a fucking Tesla shows up.
- Wow.
- And I was just like,
this is an Uber, right?
I just called an Uber.
Yeah, a fucking Tesla shows up.
And I'd never ridden in
a Tesla before, right?
- Right.
- Have you guys ever ridden in a Tesla?
- No, I haven't.
- Yeah, so I didn't know how they worked
because the first thing you normally go
when you go to a car
is you go and you pull the handle.
Right, so I go up to this Tesla
and there's no handle.
It's literally a flat handle place
so I didn't know you
were meant to push it in
and the handle comes out.
I was like, "Daddy Elon has designed
some fucking futuristic
travel to Mars fucking stuff."
It's probably electric
so I'm standing there
in front of the Tesla
thinking it's an automatic door going.
(all laughing)
So I'm like, uh.
- [Connor] Did he have to open it for you?
- Yeah, he had to come out
and just tell me just
to push the handle in.
- I just imagine Garnt
just being like, "Open!
Open!"
(all laughing)
- Daddy Elon, please.
- Where is it?
Uh!
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Was it fun though?
Riding in a Tesla?
- It was very fun.
- Yeah?
- It was-
- It's a toy.
- Huh?
- It's like a toy
'cause it's so futuristic.
- It is, it is.
- I'm excited.
- It's cool though.
- Yeah, it was weird
seeing the pad at the front
just completely track
everyone, all the cars
but when it came to pedestrians,
it was just fucking freaking the fuck out
because there's so many
pedestrians in London.
- [Connor] Oh, in London, yeah, true.
- So just seeing humans
appear then disappear,
then this dog was a human then it wasn't.
But it was very cool.
It is very much a toy.
I know our mates' parents
owns one as well and-
- [Connor] Yeah, never shuts up about it.
- Huh?
- Never shuts up about it.
- Yeah, never shuts up about it.
- He drives it
and he's like, "Oh, my
mum bought it, though."
He doesn't mention that.
He says, "My Tesla."
Our Tesla.
- Our Tesla.
- Yeah, 'cause he took you on plenty of-
- Yeah, I went in his Tesla.
Yeah, I got shit in the car.
I tell you about that? Remember that?
I almost shit in the car, remember?
- Have we told that on-
- No, I haven't.
- Have we talked about
that on "Trash Taste"?
- No.
- We haven't.
- So we were driving in this
Tesla in the countryside
and the Tesla,
'cause it had been sitting there all day,
I had the window down.
- Yeah.
- (chuckles) And I can't
remember exactly what happened,
but we were driving along
this really country road
and then, oh no, I remember what happened.
We're driving along this country road.
It's kind of dirt road.
It's not the cleanest road, we're going.
And then he's trying to show
off that it can go 0 to 60 in,
you know, as every car owner does,
they have to prove that the car's fast.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- As if normal cars don't go fast.
So we're going fast.
And as he speeds up, there's a,
I don't know if it's a harvester
or something plowing
the fields next to us.
No, it's the machine that spreads manure.
- Oh, okay, yeah, yeah.
- So as it's spreading it, we're going by
and then before I know it-
- Oh no!
- I'm chilling like this in the car
and then suddenly just
a fucking wave of manure
starts hitting my face
and goes in the car.
and it's launched into this Tesla.
And then everyone is doing
that thing of kind of like,
aah, aah, aah, aah, oh God, oh God!
Aah!
And then there's just shit
everywhere in his Tesla
and he just got it cleaned a week before.
- And it's white seats as well-
- Yeah, it's white seats.
- Pure.
- It's white seat Tesla.
- Oh no.
- And the inside is pure white.
Absolutely dickhead white.
- Oh my God.
- You should never have
your interior this color
for this reason
and so there's just, oh God.
And the entire car journey,
it just smells of cow shit.
It just absolutely reeks of cow shit.
And he's freaking out cause
it's his parents' Tesla
and he's borrowing it.
And so he's like, (spluttering).
Oh, what am I gonna do?
Oh, oh.
He's freaking out.
I'm like, "Don't worry,
we'll get it cleaned,
we'll get it cleaned."
He's like, "Oh my God, my
parents are gonna kill me."
And so we-
- So anyway, about that 0 to 60.
(all laughing)
- And there's chunks this
big of manure in the car.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's just, and then
the smell is just everywhere.
- [Joey] My God.
- So we go into a Pizza Express afterwards
and we just stink of shit
and we're just eating pizza.
And then I think he goes to get it-
- They must have been so confused
because the people working there's,
it's just a bunch of dudes
just smelling like shit eating pizza
and they're like, "Oh, man,
they fucking live like this?"
Meanwhile, they head
back into their Tesla.
(all laughing)
- It was so-
- Like what the fuck?
- It was so, and then I think
he got it cleaned the next day
or the day after 'cause he was so angry.
He's like, "I have to get it cleaned,
I have to get it cleaned."
So he got it cleaned.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember him building up
that he's like, "Oh my God,
my parents let me borrow the Tesla.
Guys, I'm driving the Tesla,
I'm driving the Tesla."
And it was just this massive
event in our friend group
that Eugene's coming in a fucking Tesla.
- Damn.
- Day after, Connor's just like,
"Guys, I got shit in Eugene's Tesla."
- We were going a country road,
I'm the kinda guy, I don't know why,
I don't know why people wanna do this
but I just wanna put my arm like this.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course, of course.
I get that.
- I don't know why.
- [Joey] I get that.
- And so yeah, then obviously
I couldn't have predicted
that a bunch of manure
was gonna fly in the car.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But it did.
- Oh my God.
- That's a funny story.
- (indistinct).
- I remember just feeling bad for Eugene,
but also laughing
- It was very funny.
- Laughing very, very hard.
- I was covered in shit,
but it was so funny at his anger
that his Tesla was covered in shit
that it canceled out me
being covered in shit.
- [Joey] It was worth it.
- I wasn't too bothered
about being covered in shit.
'Cause it wasn't like I was going
to a formal dinner or something.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was going to Pizza Express
and I'm gonna get drunk.
I was like, "Whatever, fine.
I'll just clean it,
I'll clean the clothes.
Not the end of the world."
- Yeah.
- That's so funny.
- But yeah, it was good.
- I also, recently I
watched, yesterday in fact,
this is good timing,
I watched the new "Doctor Strange" movie.
- Oh yeah, how was that?
- Oh, how is it?
- Very mid.
- Really?
- Is it actually?
- It was probably one of
the most boring movies
I've watched in the long time.
- Really?
- Oh wow, okay.
- 'Cause I heard-
- Damn-
- A lot of good things about it.
- I'm sad, I was really excited for it.
- Watch it, make your own mind up.
I also watched it in Dolby Atmos
and I was way too close to the front
and I really regret it
'cause some of that fucking sound effects.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- There's this one sound
effect in the start
where he summons a saw and I swear to God,
it nearly punctured my
ear, this saw sword.
But yeah, no, it was weird.
It was all over the place.
The thing that I don't like
about "Doctor Strange,"
and I don't know if
anyone else feels this way
is that I don't know what
the fuck his powers are.
It's just whatever he needs to do.
- Yeah.
It's just like, he's like, oh, ta-da-
- [Garnt] He does the circle thing, right?
- I do a circle, then
now I summon a monster
and now I summon a boat and it's like,
I don't know what fuck
the your abilities are.
I don't know.
No one has ever taught,
there is never a scene where
he's learning these powers.
- Yeah.
- Individual spells.
How does this work?
- I've always just said his power
is like the Metronome move in Pokemon,
where it's just like, he
just waggles his fingers.
And then something happens, you know?
- It's like, I don't know
what the fuck is going on.
And the entire movie feels
like when you're kids
when you're eight years old
and you pretend like
you have a magic fight
with your childhood friend.
You're like, "And I summon this,
I do this, I do this back!"
That's what the whole movie felt like.
It was just that.
- Isn't that just a JoJo fight?
- Yeah.
- But at least JoJo,
there's some tense to it.
There's some intensity.
This entire fight was like, all right,
well of course he's gonna win.
And then there's just this.
And there's just like, what
the fuck is this movie?
I don't know what fuck the is going on.
It's so stupid.
This entire movie was just like,
all right, now this, all right, now this.
And now this!
And it's like, "What is happening?"
- Yeah I heard from comic book fans
that Doctor Strange is meant to be
one of the most powerful beings
in the Avengers or whatever.
- Right.
- And they've just completely
nerfed him in the MCU
or something like that.
Because I have no idea what
the fuck his ability is
apart from just summoning the circle thing
and summoning the teleport.
Basically, it's just Paul, right?
He just has the Paul guy.
- Maybe the character in
the comics is interesting
but I was so fucking bored in this movie
and then halfway through they,
'cause it's the multiverse
and then they introduce
other Marvel characters
from other Marvel.
And then it's supposed to be,
I guess just comic book boner moments
where I'm just supposed
to be impressed that-
- They included that scene!
- That a guy from the X-Men turned up
and I'm like, "I don't give a fuck.
I'm not impressed by this."
There's just a moment where he'll come in
and then the music will play,
the stereotypical, oh, it's a character
you're supposed to know.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- Dun, dun!
And then it's like, all right, cool.
And now, and then he's dead.
And then it's like all right, okay, cool.
Okay, fair.
What is happening, dude?
- Oh, is it because you
just haven't watched
many MCU movies since?
- I've watched a lot of them,
I've watched a lot of them
and this was, the only one I
haven't watched was "Eternals"
'cause I heard it was complete doo doo.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And "Captain Marvel," I didn't watch.
'Cause I heard it was really bad.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- This is probably one of
the worst ones I've watched.
- So you've watched every Marvel movie
post "Endgame" as well?
- Post "Endgame," what has that been?
Just "No Way Home."
- There's been "No Way Home,"
there's been "Black Widow"-
- I've watched "Black
Widow," that was God awful.
- [Camera Person] (indistinct)
(speakers drown each other out)
- They've been taking big Ls, I feel.
These movies have been...
- I just feel like they
are still building up.
- "No Way Home" was really good.
- "No Way home" was fucking great.
- But that was 'cause I got
what I wanted outta that.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
yeah, I kind of expected to see,
it's part of that movie, and yeah.
- Yeah, I'm sad because I'm not that hyped
for any new Marvel movies coming out.
And "Doctor Strange" was one of the few
I was actually hyped about.
I was really hyped about "No
Way Home" and that met my-
- [Connor] That was good.
- That met my expectations.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- Oh, he's already here?
- I just felt that it was like,
You know when you watch a movie
and I wanted to watch
it to give my thoughts.
But at the same time, I'm like,
fuck, I didn't wanna give them money
so they think that I want more of this.
- Right.
- 'Cause I don't want more
of this.
- Right.
- I'd rather, I don't know.
I heard "Morbius" was really, really bad.
- I've heard that's the worst Marvel movie
of anything Marvel related of all time.
- It's not Marvel is it?
It's Sony.
- Okay, that's not MCU.
- So it's not exactly MCU
but obviously Jared Leto
is apparently really bad.
I don't know, maybe watch
it and give me your thoughts
'cause I'm really torn on it
'cause there were some moments
that I thought was really interesting
and I thought, okay, this is good.
But the rest of the time, I'm like,
this just felt like a
movie they wanted to make
just because they were like, well,
I guess we could get Benedict
Cumberbatch to act himself out
through times and that could be fun.
And it's just like, all right.
And I don't know, it was just
really long winded and boring.
And the moment my popcorn ran
out, I was kind of out of it.
- Kinda done.
- I was kinda like, I was like-
- That was the final straw.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, well, there's no
reason for me to be here now.
- I went with Emily and Daidus
and they were just laughing
all the time as well
at some of the,
some of the dialogue was so bad.
- Did they enjoy it?
- They thought it was really bad as well.
- Okay, okay.
- So they were enjoying
it ironically, I guess.
- Yeah, there were some lines of dialogue
that it was just like, "Who wrote this?"
This was completely absurd.
This is like a four-year-old wrote it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't know, maybe
viewers, maybe I'm wrong,
maybe you disagree with me.
Let me know what you think.
I haven't looked at any
critical reviews of it
so I don't know critics are saying,
but I would give it a four-
- It's the 10 out 10 masterpiece!
(all laughing)
- For me, it's a four out of 10.
I was very bored.
- Is it the worst Marvel
movie you've seen?
- No.
- What's the worst one you've seen?
- "Thor 2" was pretty bad.
- Oh, that was pretty bad.
- That just sounds bad from the name.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] "Thor 2" is pretty boring.
- I'm looking forward to the new "Thor."
- Yeah, just seems fun.
- That seems fun.
- "Thor 3."
- Yes, "Thor 4."
- "Thor 4"!
- Yeah, "Thor 4."
- Four!
- I don't know.
- "Thor 4."
- Do you have Marvel movie fatigue?
I'm just like-
- I don't know-
- Just make "Blade" and
make it good (indistinct).
- I definitely have Marvel movie fatigue
in the sense where I'm just watching it
just to keep up and there are few-
- I had Marvel movie fatigue
after "Iron Man 2."
- I just feel like they're
fumbling right now.
They're like, "What are these movies?
What are they making?"
I don't know what the fuck
they're trying to sell out.
- I don't think they're fumbling,
I just think once you end with "Endgame"
and it's just an end
of 10 years of buildup,
it's just like, well, fuck,
how long is it gonna take
to build up something
that's going to be as exciting?
Because right now,
I'm not even invested in
the characters as much
that I was fucking Iron
Man or Captain America
or the main guys in the
previous generations.
So it's like, who's going
to be that main guy?
And I thought it was
gonna be Doctor Strange.
I thought that was a possibility.
- Probably will be.
- Possibility, I don't know.
- I'm just a resident sleeper, dude,
that entire...
I kinda shut off for the first hour.
I was really bored.
- Yeah.
- Watching "Shang-Chi" was cool
but I'm just like, I'm
watching a (indistinct) movie
and then you have
you're barely relating this
to the MCU somehow, whatever,
I'm not really, I don't
really care about that.
I'm here for the cool fights.
- I was watching YourMovieSucks
and he was doing his review
of all the films of the year-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And 70% of them, he was
like, "I didn't finish,
it was shit."
- Right, right, right.
- And then a lot of people got angry
'cause they were like, "Oh,
how can you review a film
if you didn't finish it?"
But I was like, I mean, surely
if you can't finish a film
that says-
- That says something.
- More than anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like how critical
do you want to be.
It's more like,
yeah, you can say you really
didn't fucking like a movie
and not finish it
because I've done that plenty
of times with anime, you know?
But if you want me to
properly critique it,
then there's only so much I can critique
without seeing all of it
because I didn't see all of it.
It's a nuanced argument,
but I think you should very
much be allowed to say,
"Yeah, I thought something sucked
because I didn't finish it."
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know?
- Exactly.
- I know, yeah.
I feel like if I was watching
that many movies as well,
I wouldn't be-
- Yeah, you gotta start using
your time wisely, right?
You don't wanna waste
your time on something
that you think is just gonna be,
your opinion's not gonna change on it
regardless of if you finish it or not.
- You know what the best TV show
that I've watched that came out recently?
- "Severance."
- Yeah, dude.
- I watched that too.
- Dude.
- What the fuck.
- Yeah, oh my God.
'Cause I was gonna talk
about some good shit
that I've watched recently.
- "Severance" is probably
one the most interesting
and best TV shows I've
watched in a long time.
- Sell it to me.
- So I'm gonna do a bad version,
then Garnt can do the good version.
- Okay, okay.
- The plot of this world
is that there is a
procedure that you can get
that'll split your mind into two.
So you have two consciousness,
one that goes to work and one
that does everything not work.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- So essentially there'll
be two characters
in the same body.
And they don't have any
memories of the other.
- [Joey] Oh, okay, okay.
- So the person in work
only existence is work
and they don't know anything else.
- [Joey] Right.
- And the person outside of
work only has outside of work
and doesn't know anything else.
And so it's kind of really interesting
'cause it's dealing with, all right,
well, if you only worked all the time,
you would probably get miserable
and want to not work all the time.
So then they're trying to,
there's really interesting side plots
of when they're trying to figure out
what their outside person is doing.
And then the outside
person's trying to figure out
what the inside person's doing.
- [Joey] Oh cool.
- And the company they work
at is really mysterious.
We don't really know what they do.
And so it's kind of like,
and it's very, very creepy and-
- Cool.
- It's pretty interesting.
You should watch it.
- So what's the good version?
- That was actually pretty good.
- You did it.
- Try and sell extra, fluff it up.
- I'll do the bad version, I guess.
- Okay.
- Imagine "Black Mirror" was good again.
(Connor laughing)
- But they had a good
premise and they ran with it.
- Yeah, okay, okay.
- Yeah, 'cause I watched the season
and it felt very "Black Mirror"-esque
but when "Black Mirror"
had very interesting ideas
and wasn't just fucking just-
- [Connor] Miley Cyrus, Hannah Montana.
- Going to the bottom of the barrel,
being like, yeah, we can make
a fucking episode about this.
But it has a very interesting
concept, as Connor just said.
And they run with it and they
explore every single facet
that I wanted to explore out of it.
They definitely bring out
the ethical aspect about it as well
of just, is, if you
separate your memories,
is that person essentially a new person
or is it just still you?
You know what I mean?
'Cause in a certain argument,
they are both the same person
because you come from
the same personality.
You just don't share
the memories of working
and the life outside of work.
But if you separate the memories,
does that mean that's two separate people
that are living in one body as well?
- Chris really liked it too.
And Chris, funnily enough, watched it.
It's on Apple TV though, which-
- Well, if Chris watched it,
it must be a masterpiece.
- Chris really liked it too.
Everyone I know who's watched it-
- No, that sounds really cool, though.
- Literally, everyone
I know who watched it
really enjoyed it.
- That definitely sounds
like a show I would like.
- Yeah, and no one's talking about it
'cause it's on Apple TV.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The only reason that
I was able to watch it
was because we were luckily
provided iPads by GeeXPlus.
- Right, right, right.
- To use for work.
And I'm just like, great,
I have a device to watch it on now.
Perfect, 'cause I couldn't do that before.
- Oh cool.
- I pretty much just saw an
article where they were like,
"Apple TV has some really
interesting shows,"
and it came up and I thought,
wow, that looks really good.
- Yeah.
- And then the reviews
were insane.
- Yeah.
- And I thought, wow, okay.
And yeah, honestly I really hope
it doesn't mess up the landing
'cause season one was really, really good.
- Season one is really,
really good and holy fuck,
did they end-
- That cliffhanger
- On a cliffhanger.
- Oh boy.
- God fucking dammit.
- Oh, but that's also scary, right?
'Cause people were saying
the same thing about
"Black Mirror" as well.
They were like, "Damn, season one, though.
Hope they stick the landing."
- Yeah, I think "Black Mirror's"
basically not gonna continue
'cause it's in legal
battles for ownership.
- Oh really?
- Right.
- Yeah, it's in legal trouble.
- Oh shit.
- I think when they sold their rights,
something was iffy and there's arguments
over who owns the rights
to "Black Mirror."
So I think pretty much,
"Black Mirror's" dead.
- Damn.
- Yeah.
- I think.
- Well, that doesn't sadden me too much
because they were definitely-
- Running out of ideas.
- They were definitely
running out of ideas.
- Something scratched that itch though.
And it was the show, so I'm glad.
I'm glad we got something.
- Oh yeah, that's good.
- (indistinct).
- Yeah, because, yeah,
with "Black Mirror," I remember
season one and season two
being fucking incredible.
- Yeah.
- And then season three was just like,
"Okay, there are some really good episodes
and then some are just
really weird episodes."
And then season four onwards
was just, why are you
putting Miley Cyrus in this?
- That's-
- I didn't even get to that point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And season five was even worse, Jesus.
- I didn't even watch season five, no.
- It sucked.
- Yeah, so I mean,
there's only so many ideas
you can come up with
with it being an anthology
of different ideas
but "Severance," fucking great
'cause it's just one idea
just explored to the fullest.
Very happy.
- Such good acting as well.
- Yeah.
- The acting is so good.
All these characters are so creepy.
- Yeah.
- And believable.
- It's so cool.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, it was perfectly casted, as well.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Definitely check it out
before it gets too hype.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- And then you won't watch it.
- Yeah, then I won't watch it, yeah.
(all laughing)
If another person starts talking about it,
I'd be like, no, I don't wanna-
- Currently, no one is talking,
I literally don't know
anyone who's talking,
I never see anyone talk about it so, yeah.
If you want a really interesting TV show-
- I gotta watch it before
this episode goes live
in a couple of days.
- I guarantee, if you watch
one episode, you'll be hooked.
It's one of those shows
where it starts so strong
and it's really interesting.
- Sure, sure.
- Yeah, watch it if you can.
It's really interesting.
Actually, yeah, amazing.
Amazing show.
- Cool.
- Speaking about something
that everyone seems to
be talking about now
that I hang out with
- "Spy x Family."
- Fucking "Spy Family."
- Oh my God.
- I didn't know how
big it had gotten here.
In the UK, even people
who barely watch anime,
they're like, "Yo, you
watching "Spy Family"?
- Really?
- Or "Spy x Family"?
I'm like, "Oh my God."
- Fuck.
- Everyone-
- I pronounce the x
'cause I'm a chad.
- It's pronounced
Spike's family, actually.
(all laughing)
- Spike's family.
Yeah, I mean, it's been a while
since I've just seen an anime
just blow up this
quickly, I guess, 'cause-
- I mean, right from the get
go, it was fucking solid.
- I mean, the manga was
insanely popular in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think it was-
- But I remember I was so scared
'cause I've been a fan
of the manga for ages now
and when I was about to
watch the first episode,
I was like, please, please let it be good.
Please don't fuck this up.
And thank God they didn't.
- Right.
- But I wasn't expecting,
yeah, as you're saying,
I was not expecting it
to be the talk of the town, essentially.
- Yeah, 'cause I expected,
because I just feel like holy fuck,
Shonen Jump are just on a
different level right now
in terms of making mega hitters
because it feels like,
it feels like when Shonen
Jump release new anime,
it's like Shonen Jump, and
then every other anime.
- True.
- Pretty much.
- 'Cause it doesn't even feel
like you're talking to a anime fan
if they say they watch Shonen Jump stuff
because everyone's
watching Shonen Jump stuff.
- Imagine if we got a
good "Berserk" adaptation.
- Just imagine.
But even so,
I even don't think it would be
as popular as "Spy x Family"
or "Demon Slayer" or something like that.
I think the only IP
that can really stand
up to Shonen Jump IPs
is "Attack on Titan."
- Yeah.
- And that's the outlier, you know?
- Which is just a
different Shonen magazine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Final season part one deluxe edition.
- Yeah.
- (indistinct).
- Yeah, but I mean, it's just,
I haven't read the
manga of "Spy x Family,"
it's just a really, really good show.
- I haven't watched it
yet, I've been saving it
'cause I wanna binge it all
for one big serotonin boost.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's really solid.
- Yeah.
- Even from a manga read,
it's really, really
solid adaptation, yeah.
- There's nothing I
can really say about it
other than it's just a
good show from a good manga
with a fucking amazing adaptation.
They nailed Anya.
As a character-
- We're gonna be seeing
reaction images of her
for the next four months, at least.
- I know, right, I know.
She's so-
- Every Twitter.
- Oh my God, she's so fucking adorable.
- Yeah.
- She will single handedly
save Japan's fucking
aging population, man.
- Depression been mad
quiet since Anya came out.
- The Japanese population that
aren't having enough babies,
one Anya.
- You can have this!
You can have this right now!
- This is all you can have, okay.
- This is what you're missing out on!
Yeah, 'cause that was the
only thing I was worried about
was because the dialogue
is what made "Spy Family"
so fucking good in the manga
so I was like,
if they nail the voice
acting and the casting,
this is gonna be huge.
And they fucking nailed the casting.
- Yeah.
- At least, especially the Japanese one.
The voice for Anya is perfect.
- Yeah, I think the big thing
that really makes it stand out
is the cast really nailed the chemistry
between the mum, dad, and the daughter.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Obviously Anya gets all the spotlight
but just the dynamic,
seeing the dynamic play out between,
if you don't know the
premise of "Spy x Family,"
it's a family that has a
spy in it and assassin in it
and Anya who is a kid-
- Can read minds.
- Mind reader, yeah.
- That has telepathy, right?
It's a really, really weird mix of people
but they nail this
family dynamic perfectly
'cause I remember just
it's equal parts funny
and wholesome as well.
I remember seeing-
- It's like an (indistinct)
that's actually funny.
- Little bit of everything.
- A little bit of everything.
- A little sprinkle of everything.
- Yeah, a little bit of everything
'cause I remember coming back
from the wedding last weekend
and I remember, oh, the newest episode
of "Spy x Family" just came out.
I watched it and I just thought,
I was already high up on positive vibes
and "Spy x Family" gave
me such wholesome vibes
that I almost fucking cried
just 'cause I'm like,
just 'cause of how
fucking happy I felt, man.
- I love how you're just
like, "Fuck the wedding,
a new 'Spy Family' episode
just came out, dog."
That's where my happiness is right now.
- [Connor] Real shit.
- Yeah, that's the real shit.
- I never thought I could
burst full of wholesomeness-
- Garnt's at the altar like this, bro.
Oh shit, oh fuck.
- It's like, yeah happy for you.
Oh, Anya.
- Yeah, I'm just like,
"Hold on Sydney, hold on.
Before you say your vows,
all right, I'm ready now.
I'm ready, I'm ready."
- Opens his wallet,
it's just a picture of Anya.
It's like, that's what I'm fighting for.
- [Connor] Real shit.
- That's what I'm fighting for right now.
- Are you watching the
anime of "Spy x Family"
or are you just-
- No, no, no, I am actually watching it
because, yeah, I watched the first episode
and I was like, "Oh shit,
this is actually a fucking
amazing adaptation."
So, yeah, I am watching it.
I'm not caught up to the
latest latest episode, but.
I'm watching it kind
of on and off and yeah,
it's fucking great.
I can see why people are hyped about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, you know, you were saying that,
oh yeah, Anya's the new favorite
but I don't know, man.
I've seen a lot of fucking Yor-
- I have, I have, I have.
- Pictures and it's like oh my God.
- I know which character
you're talking about,
I don't even know what their name is.
You said the name, but-
- Yor.
- I'm guessing it's the woman, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like oh my God, first
time in God knows how many years
where waifu of the season
is not a high schooler.
So thank God.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- Well done.
- It's a mother, it's a MILF.
- It's a mother.
- It's a MILF.
- It's actually a MILF, thank you.
Well done, guys.
- I guess I'll have to check it out.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, it's so weird
just 'cause obviously I
expect it to be popular.
I didn't expect it to be
this popular this quickly.
Even "Demon Slayer" took 18 episodes.
- Yeah.
- To really burst in popularity.
- "Spy Family" just literally took two.
- Be good to see if it sticks
around for the entire run.
- I think it will.
- I would be very surprised
if it's only one season.
'Cause the manga's doing insane
numbers right now as well.
- Yeah, I saw the manga sales
of the last month in Japan
and it's number one, number two,
number three, number four, number five,
all volumes of "Spy x Family."
- That's how it always is with the anime.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause an anime comes out, all right,
and manga gets a giant boost in sales.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause people wanna read the manga.
- Yeah, so I'm like, man, Shonen Jump
just can't miss right now 'cause this,
I didn't even think "Spy x Family"
was going to be the big show
that they released this year.
I thought it was gonna be-
- [Joey and Garnt] "Chainsaw Man."
- Yeah.
- And then "Spy"-
- When is that coming out?
- That's coming out this year as well.
- No, I think it's the summer, I think.
- Okay-
- Summer-
- Next season, I think.
- I feel like that's been,
everyone's like, "I'm so hype for that."
And I'm just like, "Yeah,
weren't we hype a year ago?"
Wait, what's going on with that?
- Dude, Fujimoto just released
three one-shots in that span.
- [Connor] Oh my God, dude.
- Which you fucking need to read.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
He brought out a,
I recently read a one-shot
called "Goodbye, Eri."
- Right.
- Yeah.
- By him, and it's fucking amazing.
It's probably one of the best
one-shots I've ever read.
The dude manages to
basically give the plot
of a movie's worth of plot in 200 pages.
- Oh wow.
- And it's fucking incredible.
Yeah, I read it the other
day 'cause Twitch chat
was like, "Have you read
it, have you read it,
have you read it yet?"
And so I was like,
and you can read it for free as well.
On the Jump+, I'm making
it sound like an ad.
I'm not even paid for this shit.
- [Connor] (indistinct).
- Thanks, Shueisha.
I'll wait for my royalties.
- Do they need us to shout them out
to know that Shonen Jump exists?
- No.
So Jump+ is on another
fucking level right now.
- It's like being like, yeah,
shout out to Disney, by the way.
Loving the stuff you're
doing with Marvel, whatever.
- They own the entire world.
- Waiting for the royalties soon, Disney.
Walt, I'm waiting for your call, Walt.
- Yeah, I mean (indistinct)
'cause even Disney now
have also come into the anime
race, you know, fucking.
They've picked up one of the
best seasonal animes, I think,
is (indistinct),
which is like "Summertime Render,"
which no one can really
watch right now because-
- Yeah.
- Is it on Disney+?
- It's on Disney+.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, yeah.
It's on Disney+
and it's a Disney+ exclusive.
But they're not releasing it-
- Back in my day, all the anime
was on one platform.
(Garnt chuckling)
- [Camera Person] One
more anime that was aired
a couple of seasons back
is in Disney+ as well.
- What?
- [Camera Person] (indistinct).
- Is it actually?
- Yeah.
Fuck.
- I see ads on Facebook,
everywhere's like,
(indistinct) on Disney+.
- Fuck.
- That's so weird.
What a weird timeline we're living in
where Disney is like,
"You kids ever heard of anime before?"
That's so weird.
- It's so surreal to think
that it's gotten to this point
where now Disney is getting
involved in the anime arms race.
I thought they just,
they had their thing
with Ghibli, you know?
I never thought they
cared about anything else
outside of Ghibli.
- Yeah, I always thought
Disney's idea of anime
was just "Princess Mononoke."
- Yeah.
- That's a movie.
Anyway.
- Is it made by Hayao
Miyazaki or not, okay?
I guess it just doesn't exist then.
- Doesn't exist.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I saw you finally
completed Elden Ring as well.
- I did, Elden Ring was very fun.
- How was that?
- Great game, when are you gonna play it?
- When I-
- When I have free time.
- When I have time to invest
on being addicted to something.
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- Yeah,
Elden Ring's amazing.
- Yeah, 'cause I saw you playing it
and I'm like, God fucking damn,
that looks so fun but I know-
- It is, it's really fun.
- But I know as soon
as I start Elden Ring,
it's just gonna be like
when I started Breath of the Wild again
where-
- Goodbye productivity.
- Yeah, goodbye productivity,
goodbye free time
'cause I am doing nothing
but playing this game.
- How many hours did you sink into it?
- Nearly 70, I think.
- Okay, that's not too bad.
- On my first play through.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's really, really fun.
I got to say it's probably
one of the best games
I've played ever.
- 'Cause I know people who sank 200 hours
and still haven't beaten it.
- Well, yeah, 'cause I mean,
I like to play games on stream
and I don't really wanna,
right now, I don't wanna
keep playing it on stream
'cause I've streamed it a shit ton
but I could easily do
multiple play throughs
and enjoy every second of it.
There's some, I didn't even see all of it.
I missed so much stuff.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause it's open world
so there's just so much to do.
But yeah, honestly, really,
really amazing game.
So many cool fights, really
fun, really satisfying.
One of the best game
designs just hands down.
The world, oh my God, dude.
The world building in that game
is just second to none.
You've never seen a world built like that.
- What do you mean?
- I've never heard you talk
about world building before.
(all laughing)
- I never cared.
- I'm just like, Connor,
what, it must be fucking.
- You know something's up
when Mr. Game Mechanics over here
is like "World building, though, ooh!"
- I've never cared.
But the fact that they build
so many cool set pieces.
- Yeah.
- Just these giant areas
that you go to once
and you're like, how much hours
did they sink in building this?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And you're there for
10 minutes, you're gone.
Or this one boss fight.
And they built this whole giant thing
leading up to the boss
fight, and it's like, what,
what the fuck?
Like, oh my God, just some
of the areas you're like,
this is so cool and creative.
How the fuck did you come up with this?
- Yeah.
- Miyazaki, man.
He's build-
- It's insane.
It's insane.
The whole, I've never cared
about how a game world looks
'cause it's like, okay,
you go into a place,
the boss arena, you leave.
No, every single aspect of this world
is just so cool and tells
an interesting story.
And it's honestly such a good game.
Really, really fucking good.
- Yeah, one thing that's
really surprised me
about what I've seen people
talking about about Elden Ring
is how friendly it is to beginners.
- Oh yeah-
- And how accessible it is.
- You can do whatever you need to do.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel like
because it's open world
and because there are so many options,
in previous Souls games,
you get to a hard boss or something
or you get to this one point
and people who were not as
pro-gamer, whatever, you know-
- There's a hard skill cap, right?
- Yeah, there is a hard skill cap
where they could do nothing
aside from try to beat this boss
and if they couldn't beat this boss,
then I guess they just give up
or they just do something else
but because Elden Ring is open world,
there is just so much more opportunity.
If they find a hard boss,
then they can try doing something else,
they can grind up a bit
or I've heard that there
are many different builds
and many different variations
to whatever type of play
style you wanna do as well.
And some are definitely
easier than others.
- Oh, some are completely busted.
- Right.
What's the busted ones, then?
- It's the blood one.
There's a bleed mechanic in the game
with certain swords
that cause 'em to bleed
and does percent damage.
- Wow.
- So percent damage on bosses
you can imagine is quite big.
And some swords can apply
it very, very quickly.
So you can just chunk
through bosses in seconds
with some builds.
- Right.
- And other builds, not so much.
But I messed around in
the hard area a bunch.
And then I went to the easy area
where I think I was supposed to go.
'Cause you can do
whatever you want, really.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But then I absolutely
steamrolled this area,
two shotting bosses and stuff.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I was like,
I had gone messed around
in the really hard area
that I shouldn't have been in,
but that's the way I
enjoyed playing the game,
it was really fun.
And then it got really
difficult towards the end,
but that was really fun as well.
'Cause I was kind of
over leveled a little bit
and so it was really fun.
I just, I had a really great time.
There's not many boss fights
that I thought were bad.
All of the main bosses were sick.
So fucking cool, dude.
- Yeah.
- Such cool bosses.
Just a fun time.
Really fun time streaming it as well.
- Would you say it's as difficult
as people make it out to be?
- Again, it's as difficult
as you want it to be.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You can summon spirits and stuff.
So things that come in the fight for you
and that helps a lot
'cause it just takes aggro.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- The boss will stop hitting
you and hit something else.
So then that's more useful
than them doing damage.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But some of them do
damage as well, a lot.
- [Joey] Right.
- So yeah, I mean, it's great.
Play it, it's fun.
It's really, really fun.
- Yeah, I will definitely play it.
- I will, I just need to
find the time to do it.
- I want to there to be,
I hope there's a game that
can get game of the year
over this game 'cause I'd welcome that.
- [Garnt] That would be
incredible if there was-
- I don't know how that would happen-
- If there was a game of the year.
- I hate being that guy that's like,
"It's game of the year,"
but I don't know what-
- I don't know, man,
have you played the
new Kirby game, though?
(all laughing)
- I don't know what could-
- It's pretty fucking poor.
- In my mind, I'm like,
I don't know what could top this this year
for a gaming experience
that is collectively agreed upon
to be an amazing.
- I mean, I'd be shocked
if it wasn't that game.
- I'd be shocked.
- I'd be very shocked as well
- I'd welcome it.
'Cause that means more games for me.
- I mean, I haven't even played it
and I reckon it's gonna be it.
- The only other game that's
probably better than it
is Metal Gear Revengence
which I played.
That was fun, that was great.
- I'm just so happy the Revengence memes
have come back.
- [Connor] Have you played it?
- I haven't played it.
- [Connor] You haven't played it.
- But I feel like I've
experienced 90% of it
just through memes itself.
- Bro, it's so good.
I played it, I did it on stream
and yeah, it was amazing.
What a fun game.
Cut scenes were as amazing as you think.
- Armstrong is one of my
favorite video game characters
of all time.
- Yeah.
- How did the Japanese portray America
better than most American games, right?
(all laughing)
- It's so good.
- So good.
- It's just so cool seeing a game
that just goes beyond time.
It's so impactful that it
doesn't matter how old it is.
- I think one thing
that really impressed me
with seeing people play
Metal Gear Revengence
is just the music is just fucking insane.
- [Connor] Dude, it's so good.
- It's not just insane
but it kind of matches up
with the scene or the level
that you're playing as well.
It's just like, the amount of,
that's what sells Revengence to me
because I love anime,
like Fooly Cooly that makes it feel
like you're watching a
music video or something
as you're watching the anime.
But Revengence feels like
you're playing a music video
as you're going along.
And that's the biggest
selling point for me
with Revengence.
- It's just so good.
It's such a fun game
and the mechanics are so tight
and the cut scenes are just hilarious.
'Cause it's so overly political
that it's so funny
but also it's like some things he says,
you're like, "Oh, wow,
kinda little on the nose."
(all laughing)
And then obviously all the
memes that came out of it
are so good.
- Yeah.
- If you haven't played the
game, again, I recommend it.
- How long did it take you to complete?
- I played it on hard
and I kind of regret it.
'Cause I felt like there's
just so many very hard moments.
'Cause I wasn't very good at the game
'cause it's very fast.
- Yeah.
- I think the medium is
probably the best way
to enjoy the game initially.
And it'd be like five hours,
but it took me 10 hours
'cause I was playing on
hard and failing on bosses
all the fucking time.
- Yeah.
- So hard.
- Did you play it in
one sitting, one stream?
- Yeah, one sitting, yeah.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay, okay.
- And the last fight is so worth it.
'Cause the Armstrong is
just such a fun fight.
And it's crazy, dude.
And the button mashing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's so good.
- One way is just fucking standing there,
you're just like-
- Yeah, he's...
Nano machine, son.
I feel I'm part of the
meme experience now.
That's why, I'd played it before,
but I'd gotten halfway and I quit.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Because I got stuck
'cause it's a hard game.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Some of the boss
fights are fucking hard.
- Yeah.
- So yeah.
I mean play on normal,
if you want a chill
time or more easy, even.
- I definitely wanna play it.
- Yeah.
- You can do it in five hours.
- Yeah, okay.
Just one stream.
- And two hours is cut scenes.
- Oh, brilliant, brilliant.
My favorite.
- Yeah, it's literally-
- I mean, it is a Kojima game.
- Yeah, it's-
- You know, of course.
- It's so good.
It's so good.
If you haven't played it, go and watch it.
You've probably watched all
the incorrect telling of
and all that,
where the names come from.
And that I made it the fuck up
and making the mother of
all omelets here, Jack.
I love that-
- I fucking love that line.
That's my favorite line.
- It's so good.
- So good.
- Such a good game, fuck.
What a game, what a game.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel like I would game,
there's one console I
really, really fucking want
and it's the Steam Deck.
- You want the Steam Deck?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause so many times, I'm just not in-
- That'd be a fun game to play
on the Steam Deck, actually.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
'cause it's less about
just the Steam Deck itself
and it's more of, there's so many games
I just wanna play on the go.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Because, especially now
we're traveling so much
and I don't stream as often as you guys.
There's less time where I
sit down in front of the PC
or on a couch and I game, you know?
But if there was, that's why I like,
the console I game the most on
is probably whenever I play a Switch game
because it's just so easy to just pick up
whenever I need to play it
and just continue it
at my own convenience.
And I was always looking for a console
to play the more intensive games on.
While also going on the go
and the Steam Deck seems perfect for that
but, my God, is it
impossible to get right now?
- Yeah.
- The waiting list for that is...
- I know some people who've got it
and I'm like, "How the
fuck did you get it?
Who did you sell your blood to?"
- Yeah, I've seen the prices on eBay
and they're twice to triple the price
and the waiting list, I think
right now is a few months
so it's not too bad.
- Only a few months.
- I say that's not too bad
'cause I know the people who
got the first shipping of it,
they had to sign up a year
plus before, I believe.
- Fucking-
- I've heard mixed things about it.
There's some good things, some bad things.
But overall, I think it's good.
From what I've seen.
- What's the mixed things
you've heard about it?
- I think I saw that the,
some games it struggles with.
I can't remember what I saw.
I remember there was some downsides.
I can't remember though.
Weeks ago, I watched these videos.
- [Garnt] Right.
- I remember it wasn't perfect.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, when is it?
- When is it, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm not,
I don't really care about the frame rates
or the FPS or whatever too much.
No, I just want a competent
gaming experience on the go
for some games that I would
normally play on the PC
or somewhere else.
And that seems that's all I really want
from the Steam Deck
and that seems like the perfect console
to what I need right now.
- Seems so, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Definitely.
- Man.
- What are you playing now, Joey?
How's Kirby?
- I mean, I haven't done
the post-game stuff yet
but yeah, I don't know,
I've just kinda been fucking around
just trying to play a bunch of stuff.
I started playing Kaizo Emerald
which is one of the hardest Pokemon mods.
- Oh, okay.
- That mod is hard as shit.
It took me six hours
to beat the first gym.
- [Connor] Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, it's hard as shit.
- Well, why is it hard?
- Because not only is, well, first of all,
every trainer is unavoidable.
- Yeah.
- So you have to fight every trainer
and every trainer is optimized.
So literally every trainer fight
is like fighting a
professional Pokemon player.
- Wow.
- So the moves are optimized.
- Oh.
- And all the IVs are
optimized and everything
and you're basically
just going against that.
- [Connor] Jesus Christ.
- And it's intense as fuck.
- Have you seen those people
beating the Pokemon games
with level one Pokemon?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, they beat-
- How is that possible?
- Like Smallant and stuff, right, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause you swap
out poison, substitute,
basically all the moves that make you rage
when you have it,
you're like, I'll try and
play Pokemon competitively.
You play and then someone's just like,
substitute, mimic, poison spikes, reflect,
and it's like (hand slams) stop!
Let me hit it!
Let me hit your Pokemon!
- Literally, I knew it was bad
because for one, the first rival fight,
it just spammed sand attack seven times
and then it just slowly drained my Pokemon
to the point where I
lost the first battle.
- Oh my God.
- I was like, this isn't
gonna go well at all.
- Oh, fuck.
Yeah, I wanna do more Pokemon runs.
The Pokemon runs are so fun.
- So I'm probably gonna continue that
'cause that's just like, you know?
As a long-time Pokemon gamer, I'm like,
this is the first time where I'm like,
"Finally, a Pokemon game
is actually a challenge."
- Finally a worthy opponent.
You thought Nuzlockes were hard,
this game is fucking hard, yeah, so.
- So what's the base game that it mods?
- Pokemon Emerald.
- Emerald, yeah.
- All the mods are on Emerald, right?
- Weirdly.
- It's usually third gen, yeah.
- I wonder why.
- Usually Emerald or, I don't know,
maybe it's because it's-
- Easy to.
- A fan favorite.
I mean, it's a solid game.
- Yeah.
- But there's also
a lot of mods for gen
four and stuff like that.
- There's tons of mods for
Breath of the Wild and stuff.
I don't know how they do it, I mean,
it sounds cool, though.
- I really wanna play mods
for Breath of the Wild and Switch games,
but I'm also scared to fuck my Switch up.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, right?
Well, Breath of the
Wild is one of the games
where you can definitely see
that being a modders heaven, you know?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause you have so much
freedom in that game as it is
in the base game, you know.
I can't imagine how it would be
if it was like-
- I've seen so many
cool mod videos of that.
- I've seen everything's Among Us.
(all laughing)
I'm not kidding.
Everyone's the Among Us...
I like it, I just like it, I don't know.
- It's like the one, the
fucking PointCrow video
where when he says Shrek,
it summons 10 Shreks into the game.
- Oh yeah, yeah, I saw that one.
- Which is the dumbest video
but it was so fun to watch.
- Yeah.
- When is Among Us gonna die?
When am I gonna stop finding
Among Us memes funny?
'Cause I thought I would-
- Never.
- I feel like they've gotten funnier
and I don't know why.
- It's because
they're starting to
become ironic, that's why.
- Did you see the Among Us VR?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say, yeah.
- It actually looks good.
It looks fun.
- That genuinely looks good.
That might be a game I can finally get VR.
- I just can't wait for
the clips of Xbox mics
and someone's like this
with their Among Us.
Dude, you fucking-
- It was this guy.
- I can't wait.
I can't wait to do the credit card on VR.
You're like, fuck.
Ugh!
I'm so hype for it.
It actually looked awesome.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It looks fun.
- Really fun, yeah.
- I can't wait for it, dude.
I'm so hyped.
- Yeah, I'm hoping they
do include the voice chat
within the Among Us games this time.
- Oh, proximity.
- Yeah, proximity chat,
that'd be awesome.
- Yeah, that'd be fun.
- 'Cause I can't imagine having
to log into Discord in VR
and having to log out.
- Yeah, it's gonna have
to be proximity chat.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think.
- It would be also perfect
if you did it on the
omni-directional moving pad as well
so you literally have to run
through the halls and shit.
- That'd be so fun.
- I really wanna own those
but it just seems impractical.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- When's that coming out?
'Cause I saw the trailer-
- No idea,
they didn't have a release date
which normally means whenever
the fuck they finish it
which is probably a while.
- Which could be next year.
- Yeah, they should, I
hope they charge for it
'cause I want it to be worth their time.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, it feels like this,
because they completely
just remade the game, right?
So they've basically just
built a new game, essentially
from the ground up.
- Basically, yeah.
- Because I don't think they
could have used anything
from their previous game,
which was originally a mobile game.
- Yeah.
- To going full on VR.
- It's gonna be hard.
- So yeah.
I'm very excited
to try it out.
- Crazy.
Might finally be able to
dust off the Valve Index.
- Oh yeah.
- Valve Index which I've never been-
- I still use mine.
It's pretty good.
VRChat's pretty fun.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, VRChat's good.
- It's just such a hassle to set up.
I kind of wish I got
the Oculus or whatever
which, 'cause that just seems
so much more convenient than,
I get you get more freedom
with the Index and everything
and it's high resolution, but-
- I still haven't streamed
on my Oculus though
just 'cause I'm dreading to set it up.
- Optimize the Index
just 'cause I have the
things permanently up there.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it's super easy.
- Oh, okay.
- I literally just plug in the headset,
open up Steam and I'm literally doing it,
so it's super painless for me.
Even then, I still get tired doing it.
I get exhausted.
- Yeah.
- After three, four hours
of running around in VR,
I'm spent.
- I'm surprised you can
even spend that long.
I can't go more than two hours.
- Yeah.
- In any game, yeah.
- Seriously, dude, it's really good.
VRChat is so good.
Like the mods on it and the
games in VRChat are so good.
I'm not Zuckerberg.
(all laughing)
- Shaking his fist.
- The power's with the people, Zuck.
Don't you understand?
Yeah, but I mean, I
guess this is gonna be,
I guess we have a bunch
of guests coming on
the next episode, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So this is gonna be the
last boys episode for a while.
- For a while.
- Which I'm sure people are happy about
'cause we've had the
longest period of no guests.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I feel like you can tell
'cause people are like-
- When's the next guest?
- To be fair, it's our bad.
I mean, it's been hard
'cause the guests have been
limited 'cause, you know,
Japan has-
- We can't be like,
let's invite Chris on a
fucking 10th time, you know?
- Yeah, exactly.
- We could have invited back more guests
but we thought, we kinda
just wanna try and-
- Keep it trying fresh.
Keep it fresh.
- Obviously, Chris is the
fourth member, though.
- Basically.
- Chris is welcome back on anytime.
Basically, whenever he's
in Tokyo, he comes on.
- Yeah, so hopefully if you
guys want more guest episodes,
you'll be getting a lot coming soon.
- Now that the world is opening up,
it's kinda like the
flood gates are now open.
- I'm sure, I can't wait for the,
when are the boys gonna just
go back to the three of them.
'Cause we're probably gonna have
a lot of guest episodes in a row.
So I know people are gonna say that
'cause people do like the,
not that people don't like
the non-guest episodes,
people do actually really like them.
I know a lot of people
say that their favorites.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- But, yeah, we're gonna
have a lot of guests
and then we'll try and
sprinkle in ours between.
Be interesting to see how people like it.
- Yeah.
It's gonna be a new kind
of "Trash Taste,'" I think.
- Season three.
- I guess it kind of is season three.
- Kind of is season three.
- Yeah, it's gonna feel a bit different.
We're not gonna spoil what it is
but yeah, "Trash Taste" is
gonna feel a little different
for a time, so look forward to that.
- Yeah, hope you enjoy it.
- Hey, look at these Patreons, though.
- Yeah, right.
- Oh yeah.
- It's been so long
since I've recorded an episode,
I forgot that we had to
shout out the Patreons.
- It's like,
what was the thing we have
to say after this again?
- We have to do the
outro as well, oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God.
Yeah, but hey, if you
wanna support the show,
then go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And yeah, see you at AX, I guess
now that we've finally
said that in the episode.
- Yeah, see you there.
- Hopefully.
- See you there.
- Yeah, so if you're in
the LA area, see you then.
- All right.
- See you.
- [All] Bye.
(gentle rhythmic music)